The soccer.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen,
uh,
tomorrow live on Spike TV,
his glory world series with me,
my man Joe Schilling.
Last minute addition,
I want to talk to you about some shit,
dude.
Let's stop.
I was working out in my gym yesterday dying.
Okay.
All I'm doing is hitting pads.
No one's hitting me back.
I'm fucking exhausted.
And when I like to do,
when I'm,
when I'm working out.
And so I like to put fights on from motivation and I'm watching you and,
uh,
you're,
you're fighting in the,
the last man standing tournament.
You got to fight three times this,
this night.
You're,
you're fighting you.
You're going for fucking rounds.
Exhausting.
Ridiculous fight.
And then I remember this shit.
Oh Shit.
Oops.
I just dropped Elvis.
Elvis has left the building.
Yeah,
I remember this shit.
Right?
And this is Brian Look and sent me this picture.
What the fuck,
dude?
How are you able to have that kind of cardio?
I mean,
you fought three times that night for four rounds,
the first fight before you,
uh,
you,
won by knockout and you're,
you're smoking cigarettes.
Yeah.
How's that possible?
Oh,
Joe,
I didn't want to talk about this last time.
First five minutes of the show.
Here you go.
It's just,
I couldn't believe it.
I really have a hard time believing it.
Like I was,
I was watching the fights.
I was like,
how the fuck does this guy have this kind of energy?
Uh,
would it be honest?
I was exhausted in the third round when a,
and went back to my corner and I looked at my coach and like,
you know,
he's like,
I think you'd have to go another round.
And I'm like,
fuck,
I did not want to go another round.
I was exhausted.
Uh,
no.
I just wanted to win.
And that was,
that's kind of what it did.
Well,
it was just a ridiculous fight too.
Yeah.
I mean it was,
the whole tournament was ridiculous.
It's crazy to make someone fight three times at night,
but that,
that first fight was just so fucking back and forth and wild and crazy.
And,
and for you to go that hard,
why you smoke cigarettes?
Yeah.
I don't,
like I said,
I can't,
I can't justify it.
I'm really,
I'm about ready to quit.
My last fight,
my cardio was,
you know,
I've done kickboxing for so long where he,
I get tired like anybody else,
but uh,
for whatever reason it's never really bothered me that much.
And in the last fight he was holding me a lot and just the cardio system is
completely different and it's uh,
yeah,
it's coming to an end.
I'm getting really sick of smoking and I'm getting really sick of explaining,
having this conversation.
Joe Joe's the reason when I quit,
this will be the reason.
Well good.
Well I wanted to talk to you about these stupid vaporizing things,
but Simon Marcus,
the guy you're fighting is a tough motherfucker.
You guys going back and forth three rounds and then you'd go into the fourth
round and you still managed to knock them out in the fourth and that was a crazy
fight.
And to know that you're doing all this,
giving yourself mean,
what kind of a cardio deficit do you think cigarettes gives you?
Is it 5% may be?
Uh,
I really don't know.
I've been smoking since I was since before I started doing kickboxing.
So it was something that was just,
you know,
my cardio always sucks the beginning of the camp and then by the
end of camp and I'm out running everybody else.
And uh,
it's a,
it's,
I'm sure it's a deficit of amazing cardio if you didn't smoke,
I mean think of that.
Unless,
you know what I used to think when I was young,
I was really retarded.
I would think that maybe smoking cigarettes is like weightlifting for your
lungs.
I kept,
makes your lungs work harder because like if you smoke,
if you work out really hard and you smoke,
like maybe your lungs have to like work extra hard to deal with that smoke and
they get stronger.
I quit for one fight when,
uh,
it was my last amateur fight and uh,
my coach,
you know,
it was against it.
Obviously it was against you quitting.
Oh,
it gets me smoking.
He said,
don't be a pussy beer.
Exactly.
So,
uh,
yeah,
I quit for three months to train really,
really hard.
And,
um,
for whatever reason,
I was exhausted in the fight after the second round.
They were like,
you know,
seconds out and I'm like,
look at my coach and I can't stand up.
And my legs were like locked up and he had like lift me off the stool and uh,
I got robbed in the,
I lost that fight.
But it was,
you know,
everybody said I won the fight,
but whatever.
But uh,
that was my coach after the fight.
It was like,
you know what,
he quit,
he did everything I asked you to,
you know,
do whatever you want to do after that.
And Wow.
Yeah.
I wonder if you bought it was suffering nicotine withdrawal.
I don't know.
Or if I was overconfident and my cardio is gonna be so much better that I wasn't
pacing or something that could be right.
Yeah.
That's a big issue,
right?
That a lot of people that watch fights really have no idea the energy management
that's going on.
Like there's a whole bunch of management going on during a fight and energy
management is like a big issue.
Knowing when to,
when to blow it out.
And that's why you see like a lot of guys chill sun on the podcast said it best.
He said if you try to win by knockout but don't win by knockout,
you often lose decision.
Yeah.
You just don't have the gas to keep going.
Right.
It's pretty true.
How is that an experience thing you think?
Like when you're,
you're managing your energy like that in in the ring?
I think,
uh,
I think so.
I think it's,
uh,
it's also has a lot to do with like hiding how tired you are.
And like that example,
for example,
that fight with a seven Marcus you were talking about,
I usually,
the way I hide it and all the secrets can be out there with,
oh shit,
I'll do like a little walk off.
And if you notice like,
uh,
the ref broke us,
John McCarthy broke us and like I turned my back and I was walking away and I
was like,
that's where my breath.
And then he like,
you know,
he stalks me and as he's coming,
I'm waiting for them.
One big shot.
You know.
So it's like you're exhausted.
You,
you pace yourself for a second to give that next explosion,
the next explosion.
You know,
it's just experience.
I've,
I've always been tired and every fight I've ever had,
so I'm at that level,
you know.
But like my last fight with Bella tour,
I was just a different level of exhausted from the wrestling and Jujitsu that I
haven't been doing for 15 years of my life.
And you know,
I'm at a point now in my career where it's like I've worked my ass off for so
long that like kickboxing comes natural to me,
you know.
And with MMA it's like if I want to,
yeah,
I have half of the game down,
but if I want to really take this to the next level,
I have to improve on the ground
and in the wrestling and that's going to take me improving my cardio I think.
So.
Are you committed totally to fighting in both MMA and kickboxing or do you,
do you go back and forth on this or,
um,
you know,
I love kickboxing and I want to do it forever.
And if the opportunity stays there for me to do both,
then yes,
but I definitely have to step my game up and may if you know,
I really hate my record.
This last fight a fucking drives me nuts.
The last fight was a close one up until it got to the ground.
It just seemed like you were having a real hard time getting up.
It's like this is such a giant issue when it comes to the difference between the
kind of endurance that you have with grappling and you know,
and your,
your ability to calculate all the different moves and all the different,
like it takes so long to get grappling inflammation in your body and your head.
There's just so much stuff that's going on when guys are holding you down and
say like is a few guys that get the,
the,
the takedown defense game down like Cro,
cop did and pride and then start to become really successful.
But once they actually get taken down and actually get held down in the ground,
like it just saps you of your energy.
Right.
And it,
it takes away.
I was watching,
I was like,
I wonder how frustrating this is for him because you're used to fighting your
style of fight,
your style,
fights,
kickboxing.
Right.
You know,
and then all of a sudden you've got this guy on top of you and you can't get up
and you know,
he's holding you down and nothing really was happening on the ground.
Like there wasn't,
there wasn't a lot of ground and pound wasn't like real significant submission
attempts,
but it's just keeping you from doing the shit you want to do it right.
Yeah.
It was incredibly frustrating.
Incredibly frustrating.
Do you think about just not doing it anymore?
Uh,
not really.
Cause I,
you know,
this is not who I am.
When things are frustrating and hard,
I don't quit.
I just step it up to the next level usually,
which is,
you know,
it's something I like about myself.
So I don't want to change that.
Well,
no,
that's a good quality for sure.
It's just,
you know,
it's frustrating.
And then,
you know,
I obviously have things that I needed to work on and I,
I had stuff from the camp and I was really sick during the cap and it's,
you can continue to kickbox when you're really sick,
you know,
to an extent.
But like you can't do Jujitsu and be like drooling and slobbering and fucking
sweat and then some guys face when you have the flu,
you know?
So like for that camp,
I only had like three weeks of Jujitsu and then I was sick for three weeks ahead
of fucking bronchitis and lung infection.
That nasty shit,
which probably fucking smoking wasn't,
you know,
we just smiled while you had the bronchitis.
I was just smoking all the time.
What I wanted to ask you is about these stupid,
these stupid vaporizer things that people keep sending me.
These vape.
Yeah.
I'm actually sponsored by firebrand and it's been good.
I think I'm going to start using that stuff to,
uh,
to quit.
That's a way better thing for your lungs,
right?
I mean,
I think so allegedly,
allegedly,
you know,
I'm sure in 20 years they're going to say that was the reason that,
Joe got brain cancer.
I just,
I wonder how,
I mean,
I know that,
uh,
being a professional fighter takes a tremendous amount of and time and I wonder
like,
when I see you in glory and I see you also in,
in Beltour,
I'm like,
man,
does this guy have the amount of time that it takes to compete at the level that
you compete at in kickboxing in both?
I mean,
do you have the time to put into Jujitsu and to wrestling defense and stuff like
that?
It's,
it's,
it's been really tough,
you know,
the,
um,
at the beginning of the year I was really excited about it.
I was gonna be a busy year,
you know,
but it's really hard to have a fight and then immediately go right into another
training camp for a different style for,
you know,
for another sport.
And it's,
uh,
you know,
it's like these fight my next fight,
June 26.
And it's like I just fought and jumping right back into clutter or belts or oh,
back in it again,
which is nice cause Lisa's two in a row,
you know.
Um,
yeah,
should be good.
I'm leaving tomorrow to a Florida,
it'll be American top team for three weeks.
It makes you a good move.
I'm gonna be a sparring with Tiago Elvis for his fight with Carlos condit and
then you know,
working a lot with the wrestling team and with the king mo out there.
So that's very smart for him.
Cause uh,
you know,
Carlos and you have similar builds.
That's a,
that's a very smart fame and that's great for you too.
That's a great camp as far as like wrestling knowledge and grappling knowledge.
Right.
You know,
he said,
you know,
I'm not the kind of person that like when I lose a fight,
I'm like,
oh,
I don't want to do this shit anymore.
I'll just go to where I'm good and you know.
Right.
What do I need to do different?
I need to get with a better team that's more focused on him and man has better
wrestlers,
you know,
work this up.
I totally get that.
But I would wonder how you could do both.
Like that's what I would wonder.
I mean I could totally get you saying,
Hey,
you know what?
Right now I'm in my athletic prime.
I think that the,
the eyes are on him and may right now and I'm just going to make the jump and
just fully make the jump but to do both.
And you're still active at a world class level in kickboxing,
you fighting world champions and kickboxing and the real number one contender
right now for Gloria.
But I couldn't take care of that shit.
So statement my eyes.
The last person that you know,
I knocked outside my nose ring number one.
He beat two guys that weren't even in the top three and somehow got rank number
one to fight out to 11 I,
I'm just saying well those are good fights though.
They were good fights,
but it's San Joe
just got said it did get it gets said they've got to now like two to make the
decision though to like say if you have a camp and a,
you're going to go and do this bell tour fight in June.
Um,
and then if they offer you a kickboxing fight,
like saying August,
is that a difficult decision?
Like do you say like,
Hey,
you know,
I would rather be kickbox and were like four or five months,
really get sharpened in the groove or is it okay to bounce back and forth?
Do you do enough kickboxing during your MMA training?
Uh,
I think I can go,
I can go back and forth with kickboxing at that level.
You know,
it's,
you just cut out.
The problem is when I do the kickboxing fight and then they offered me a belts
were fight right away because when I,
if I fought Bella tour in June and then I was going to fight kickboxing in
August,
July,
end of June and July and August,
I wouldn't be doing any wrestling or,
you know,
just don't of time,
like focusing on kick boxing,
sparring,
all that stuff.
So that kind of the issue,
you know,
it was going back and forth.
Would it make any difference at all if it was a Moitai fine instead of,
um,
instead of kickboxing,
like if you're doing Muay Thai all the time and then went right into MMA where
you got a little bit more grappling,
would that have any effect?
Um,
possibly.
I mean,
I still train pretty much the same.
The difference would be the elbows for that,
uh,
is,
you know,
we're not five or clench work,
not so much.
Um,
I've still clenching with kickboxing,
just not for as long a period of time.
Um,
you know,
every referee is different.
Even with Gloria,
it's like they say no clinching,
but then you watch my fight with Simon,
they were still way longer than five seconds of clenching in there.
So,
uh,
training wise it's still the same for me.
That's one of the reasons why it was so particularly impressive that first four
round fight because Simon Marcus's Moyie Thai guy and he's known,
that's the one of his specialties is his clinch and he's just very physically
strong and he's,
he fights it draining,
kind of fight,
just really gets a holy guys and manipulates you around.
There's a lot of knees and elbows in the clinch and,
uh,
the fucking go four rounds of that guy and then fight two more times afterwards
and then against Wayne Barrett and fucking art 11,
like,
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
When I was walking out or limping out for the,
you know,
after I beat Simon the first time I was like on a high and then beating,
uh,
Wayne,
it was just like,
fuck,
I gotta fight.
It was,
there was no high.
It was like,
I like fucking one more fight after this is crazy.
And,
uh,
we were in the back dressing room and everyone's just kind of,
everybody was just in shock and just kind of looking at me like,
how are the fuck are you going to do this?
And I'm looking at them and like,
I have no fucking idea.
I'm going to do this right now.
And I was limping to the ring and I'm just like,
when was this?
When was the cigarette?
That cigarette was right after the fight with uh,
Robert Thomas in the dressing room.
Ryan Lochte loco shut up my dress room before I got in the shower and it was
like taking pictures and I'm like,
he's like,
can I,
can I take,
I won't take a photo.
I'm like,
Ryan,
just take the picture
here.
This now.
When you fought in a tournament,
you didn't have any cigarettes in between fights or anything?
Did you have to Simon?
I went outside and had a serious,
true story.
Oh my God,
you got a cigarette and then fought twice more.
I mean for all this cigarettes like I should,
we get sponsored by Marlboro.
Right?
You should fuck the Reebok deal in Marlborough.
What's up?
Cowboy gets sponsored by Budweiser.
Does he?
He's always wearing Budweiser shirts that gotta be thrown him some cash.
I can't imagine.
He's not.
Yeah,
I don't seem to do it without a Budweiser shirt on.
Yeah.
I could be their poster boy.
Well if anybody would like,
like marble would love you.
Yeah.
Like look at this fucking guy.
You know.
What do you smoke?
What kind of smoke?
My rear lights.
There you go.
They'd probably be like,
look folks,
the lights are okay.
Yeah.
Hey,
this guy's got great.
Cardio is perfect.
How does a man fight so many rounds?
You know,
three different guys one night.
Come on.
It's not that bad.
Right?
Don't be a pussy.
Yeah.
Those,
um,
those vaporizer things though,
they did have helped a lot of people.
Right?
Like what about gum?
You ever try that shit?
I can't stand it.
And just nicotine gum not to do it.
And I'm like you just to keep it good for your mouth.
John on fucking nicotine.
I don't think nicotine is really as bad as the chemicals that are in it.
And the burning of the,
um,
the,
the plant matter.
I think there's something about the burning of the actual leaves themselves and
then the,
the 500 plus chemicals that the cigarette companies put into cigarettes to
enhance the flavor and to enhance the addictive properties of it.
So there's a,
an interesting topic.
So now,
uh,
Philip Morris is making their own,
we'd products now,
I heard that they had,
uh,
you know,
they had some big fucking thing and that they're,
they're,
they're getting ready for the whole distribution of,
yeah.
So I have like Marlboro cigarettes.
So it's like you go ahead and take something like natural and healthy and then
give it to a,
a cigarette company and watch what happens.
And then all people will be getting fucking cancer and all kinds of shit from
smoking weed.
Yeah,
right.
They'll become republicans.
Like something will happen.
They'll put some shit in the cigarettes and you're like,
you know what?
I'm not,
I don't think I'm real excited about gay marriage.
And he's like,
all of a sudden,
sudden people have these weird Republican right wing views.
Um,
I think that,
uh,
it's real possible cause if you see those natural cigarettes like those,
American,
one of those American spirits,
spirits,
those are just tobacco,
right?
Apparently they taste like shit.
No friends smoking will not,
that'd be fun.
And they'll burn forever,
which I guess is without the chemicals like a cigarette.
If you just light a cigarette and you sit in the ashtray,
it will burn all the way down.
Like if you like a joint instead of the SGA would burn out,
you know,
it won't burn the whole thing.
But I guess it's the chemicals in it.
They like it,
they keep it lit or keep it burning and then the,
uh,
the American spirits,
it's like,
it takes forever to smoke one.
You just kind of good.
You only smoke like half of it and get rid of that.
But the disgusting,
right.
Pretty Nasty to my opinion.
Did it give you the same rush?
Like that's what you're getting,
right?
This nicotine rush,
Yeah.
I mean I guess so.
Let me give you the same feeling because I think that tobacco itself is,
I don't think it's good for you,
but I don't think it's nearly as bad for you as the tobacco with all the jazz in
it.
Yeah.
Right.
Did you ever see that movie the insider,
a Russell Crowe?
It's uh,
about,
you know,
you don't really know how much,
whenever they do a movie on real life situations,
you don't know how much fuckery is involved and manipulate things.
But the movie is about a guy who is a scientist working for cigarette companies
that his whole deal is figuring out how to make them more addictive than he
testifies against cigarette companies.
And they,
you know,
they're fucking stock in his home,
scaring the shit out of them.
And it's apparently supposedly,
supposedly,
you've got to say that based on a real story based on a real story,
but there are hundreds of chemicals,
500 plus chemicals that they put into cigarettes for various reasons.
Yeah.
Why would they do then that menthol taste?
I want to know how got into the black community.
How did uh,
men,
Coles?
Yeah.
The Nike Nike Sign,
isn't it?
Hmm.
No,
that's the new port is in Newport and before it has the Nike side,
I don't know how they do it.
Cools.
That's true.
Right cools.
It was like,
it's interesting how like certain cigarettes are for,
I mean they're just fucking cigarettes,
but they figured out a way to brand them.
So they appealed towards certain ethnic groups.
You know,
like lucky strikes.
You got to be some sort of a savage like mechanic with fucking a missing Pinky,
you know,
if you're drinking,
if you're smoking,
those filtered lucky strikes you trout probably drinking Pabst blue ribbon
writer that can,
you know,
write your,
your uh,
your,
your fingernails are always dirty.
He drinking,
you're drinking horrible booze and you smoking lucky strikes.
Everybody knows that you don't see black people smoking lucky strikes when it's
time you saw a black guy smoking American spirits.
Now there's a white hipsters,
right?
Yeah,
pretty much.
Yeah.
Try to be natural.
But Kools I just remember cool.
So like there was an Eddie Murphy movie and it was,
they would always have like the black guy like Glen,
my packet cools man,
give me that pack of cool.
My mother used to smoke Kools I don't know what that says about my mom can't be
good.
I want to say anything about Joe's mom.
Yeah man.
If you think,
if you see a young white Gal and she's smoking Kools and you're a black guy,
you probably think you've got a shot.
Like I see what she's doing.
She's sending out the bat signal.
It's just bizarre that there's certain cigarettes that they appeal to certain
ethnic groups.
Huh?
Never thought about that.
Yeah.
It's um,
marketing man.
Marketing is fucked.
How clean is your diet when you a,
I mean obviously you have the issue with the cigarettes,
but other than that,
the issue with the cigarettes,
how clean is your diet when you're training?
Um,
when I'm training I just don't eat like fast food and shit like that.
But that's pretty much it.
You know,
it's pretty weight management base that would think,
you know,
if my weight's good than I eat,
you know what I want.
But if it's a,
you know,
when I used to fight like once,
uh,
once 75,
one 68,
then it was like a month of low carb and it was killing myself,
chicken salads three times a day.
Oh,
so you do like,
um,
like an Atkins type deal?
Yeah,
when I do low carb.
But like it works really well to take off the weight.
Doesn't have as fuck with your energy.
Yeah.
W it would,
especially as the fight got closer and it would really start cutting back on
carbs.
Like I would try to keep carbs like a under a hundred a day.
And then as I got closer it would be like under 50.
And like last week it'd be like almost no carbs.
And then I had to find myself like pulling out in front of,
in traffic,
like your brain works off of,
of carbs and water.
So,
uh,
yeah,
it wasn't good.
When I went up to one 81 87 for glory,
uh,
it was a lot easier to make weight and my performance was way,
way,
way better.
Yeah.
I would only imagine there's gotta be a significant point of,
you know,
what you would call diminishing returns where you can only cut so much weight
where it's not going to benefit.
Yeah,
totally sound like when you see guys like Frankie Edgar that fought so well at
one 55 and he weighed one 55 and then you see other dudes that are coming down
from,
you know,
way,
way above that are oftentimes like in the high one eight glazed and t value.
Or see that guy in real life.
Wait till you meet him.
You're going to go down to American top team.
You're going to look at that guy and you go,
how in the fuck does that kind of make one 55 I mean,
it doesn't make any sense.
He's huge.
I mean,
he's fucking huge.
he's like,
you'd be one 90 I dunno,
I dunno how he does it.
You see him when he's getting ready to weigh in,
you're like,
that doesn't even make sense.
Like that's not even one 55.
Now he gets in the scale,
it says one 55.
And you're like,
well,
how's that possible?
Yeah.
I don't see a lot of those guys.
I just don't get it.
I just don't understand.
That's the dark secret of MMA.
The dark secret of combat sports is the weight cut.
It's very dangerous.
You heard about that guy that just died recently?
Kidney failure.
No,
amateur guy just died.
Just a like a week or two ago.
Yeah.
He had a kidney failure.
They,
uh,
pulled him out,
took him to the hospital.
I believe he died shortly after,
I want to say a day or two later,
but that's terrible.
Yeah.
It said fucking dehydration,
man.
It's just so dangerous.
It really is.
There really is.
I mean I had some really,
really bad cuts in the past and obviously the,
yeah,
the performance wasn't good,
but there was a couple of minutes where it was like walking to the way in like
there was,
it was a good,
uh,
at commerce casino,
there's like a long fucking stairway and like every step I would have to stop
and like when I take another step is they're like 15 minutes to get up the
stairs and it was like the doctor like check,
you know,
does like the check or whatever beforehand.
And he's like,
I'm going to let you cut another ounce if you don't make it.
Because usually they give you like two hours to make two more pounds or
wherever.
He's like,
you're not cutting anymore weight.
And I had to like tell him to come home.
I'm okay.
I have a nurse standing by,
I'm going to get an Ivy,
like I'm going to be all right.
But it was really,
really bad.
And then you know,
you see some of these guys,
uh,
which,
and he was the ultimate fighter where the guy who was like in the back cramping
and screaming,
crying,
they wouldn't let them fight.
But yeah,
I don't know why people go that that far.
It's all the wrestling,
the influence of wrestling.
Cause that's always been a part of the wrestling culture.
Like if you,
if you tried to wrestle at your natural weight,
you're a pussy and let you be like what?
You can't cut weight,
you can't,
you can't be uncomfortable.
Like wrestlers only seem to be happy when they're miserable.
Like they're,
they're happy when they're chewing ice and running upstairs.
They slide,
they're like marines and a certain way we're like marines.
You were talked to marines.
They,
they always want,
like they'll,
they'll brag about how much more miserable there time was and other people's
time.
Like they,
they take pride in the fact that they can suffer and being able to do it.
Yeah.
I mean I guess there's,
you know,
look,
it's not easy to fucking enduring misery.
I guess there's a badge of courage attached to that.
But when it comes to wrestling,
there's like a culture of being miserable.
A culture of like overtraining,
like no one overtrained like wrestlers.
I could say it's a significant issue because yeah,
you get mental toughness out of it.
Like there's no one mentally tougher than wrestlers when it comes to MMA.
Like when those guys enter into,
into MMA,
they have this,
this fucking steel determination,
like the elite high level wrestlers.
Do you get it from elite high,
real high level kick boxers as well.
But it seems like there's something about that.
The grind of amateur wrestling going through high school,
going to college,
going through,
you know,
a Olympic trials and references do the,
the,
the level of intensity and the wrestling room and the dealing,
the constantly dealing with being in a bad state physically,
like constantly overtrained they just develop this mindset of,
of driving through that cause this sounds miserable.
I mean,
I feel depressed was when you talk about it,
he wants to do that shit.
Yeah.
There's talk about,
um,
the,
the guy who runs,
um,
the,
uh,
California State Athletic Commission.
Um,
he wants to have people,
Andy Foster,
very smart guy,
had a good conversation with him.
He wants to uh,
talk to,
uh,
guys about pop.
Possibly putting some sort of a limit as to how much you can gain like till like
after the,
after the land to discourage like really bad weight cuts.
Like,
you know,
cut it to like 10 pounds,
15 pounds,
whatever the fuck it is,
whatever the number is.
What do you think of that?
Uh,
well,
I mean the theory is good,
but then you still have the same problem as before.
You get these guys that think they can cut 30 pounds and then I'll just put it
on 10 more,
you know,
and we'll then you're,
you're still fighting dehydrated.
You're going to have the same injuries and risks.
You're most risky more now cause you're not allowing them to at least get in
there healthy.
Yeah.
I agree.
You know,
I think the,
the real way to do it is probably the way someone like six weeks out.
Yeah.
You know,
and then,
and then figure out how much you would allow them.
But they would cheat them to cut weight once a week for the way.
Yeah.
They would just cut a shitload of wait six weeks out and just lie,
you know,
they'd cut 10 pounds and then you'd say,
all right,
you can lose 15 more and then now they're cutting 25 you know,
it's just seems like the other option is the day of Wayne's,
which is a terrible cause they'll cut weight then too.
Yeah,
they'll do it.
Yeah.
I don't know how to fix it other than telling people what's bad for you.
You know,
more people die I guess.
Yeah,
I'd say,
I mean would there be a benefit of making people fight it their natural way?
Like what do you,
what do you walk around and like close to 200 yeah,
I'm about two oh five right now.
And when you get into the ring,
when you fight,
like saying glory,
will you be about to home 200 some of them around like 200 pounds.
What about like making some sort of agreement with other fighters that also,
I like that lack of guy like Simon,
like just way in the day of the fight.
No cutting weight.
Like this is what you gotta wait,
you gotta wait 200 pounds.
Yeah.
Or maybe getting that big can make an opening like you okay.
You gotta be between one 90 and 200 you know what I mean?
Right.
But 10 people cut weight.
What wouldn't,
they'd cut weight to make 200.
Yeah,
but they'd be bigger.
They bulk up to like two 10 and cut down
almost.
Seems like there's no way to,
there's no way to fix it.
I guess that's a fucked up situation.
Uh,
and for people who don't know,
the real issue with a weight cutting when it comes to combat sports as opposed
to wrestling is head trauma.
Because a,
your brain takes a while when you're,
especially when you're just ingesting fluids orally,
meaning just drinking water or pedialyte or whatever.
It takes a while to get up to your brain.
But in wrestling,
that's okay cause no one's kicking you in the head right now.
When you were in MMA or kickboxing,
you got a real issue because it takes a while for it,
which is why everybody likes to go with uh,
ivy bags.
Fuck Salmon.
Almost like MMA is too much.
There's like too much going on between all the different shit you have to do.
And then also you have five minute rounds as opposed to three minute rounds of
kickboxing.
The wrestling,
kickboxing,
the,
the submissions,
like all,
all the different variables.
It's almost like you're fucking can't keep up with it.
Yeah.
There's a lot of shit going on there.
I don't know how to fix the weight.
I mean it's gotta be an issue in boxing tuna.
It was just don't talk about it.
It's not as big an issue.
It's not as big an issue because the,
the physical weight is not as big an issue.
It's an issue.
But it's not as big an issue as say like a guy who can take you down and oh is
that weight on top of you?
Right.
Cause the weight isn't going to really help you that much.
Yeah.
Like you see a guy like Chris Weidman who fights at one 85 he does not weigh one
85 right now.
If you wade Chris Weidman right now,
he's got to be well over 200 pounds.
He's a big boy and he has a hard cut to get down to one 85 and he's a UFC
middleweight champion,
you know,
so.
And he fights a very,
very heavy physical style.
Very a very aggressive gets on top.
But do it's vicious ground and pound knows how to use his weight and if you're
not prepared to that way,
like after Liotta fondom one of the first things Liotta said was,
I got to get stronger.
I just got to get bigger.
I just can't,
can't fight at this weight.
Yeah.
There's like,
you know,
some people they just gain weight easier than other people.
Like some guys in shape could be right around two oh five,
but when they're out of shape and get all the way up to like 225 pounds,
me,
I'm like two oh five to two 10 period and shape out of shape,
whatever.
Like I don't,
I don't know.
I'm not the type of guy that gets fat,
you know what I mean?
That's smart.
Well,
it's just,
I wish I could gain weight.
It would be a little easier.
You know,
if I,
for me to bulk up for a fight and do the weights and I'm drinking like 3000
calorie shakes,
like twice a day just to try to put weight on.
And uh,
it's,
I see these other guys that,
you know that,
uh,
who's that Bella tour champion Housley he posted a picture the other day and it
was like two 30.
Yeah.
Did you see there's a,
there was an article in the underground about that guy or people were accusing
him of a Mexican supplements.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I forget.
I don't like to engage in those things cause I don't know what,
who's telling the truth or who's not telling the truth.
Anytime someone fights.
Well,
was all immediate accusations.
Like that was one with a hot file.
Dos Anjos after he beat Pettis,
like everybody was saying,
oh,
he's got to be on something.
It's got to be on something.
Like,
look at them.
It's gotta be on something.
I just think anybody that does what
well they're going to say that,
you know.
And then like who say it is the fan.
Some,
the Bella tour posted a picture of me after I knocked out.
I'm Melvin and a picture when I was 17 years old
training and all the comments were like ped suddenly since I was 17.
I rarely kept believe he looks different than when he was 17.
Yeah,
that's weird.
Dude.
Said,
you mean you got older and you look different?
Yeah.
It's crazy.
Strange as fuck.
Hmm.
Dosign Jill's looks exactly the same too.
That's why it's so stupid that I was accusing him.
It doesn't mean he couldn't possibly have been on something.
But you know,
he's training with uh,
one of the disciples of um,
Marv Marinovich.
Do you know the modeling?
Yeah,
he's training with this guy nick curse on who's going to be on the podcast in a
couple of weeks.
I'm very excited to interview that guy.
And he's got some pretty radical training methods that he learned from Marvin
Marinovich cause I heard them talk about him when Bj used it.
Right.
Yeah.
And this guy has the same sort of training methods.
I really can't wait to interview him and talk to him about these,
these methods butts.
Interesting.
Yeah,
because dos Santos was in insane shape.
I mean the,
the pace that he put on pedes and he didn't have any holes.
I mean there was nothing,
nothing by striking was on point is grappling was insane.
His Cardio is insane.
I mean he just covered all the bases,
dotted all his eyes,
checked all his t's.
It was a,
that was impressive as fuck.
I want to find out what this guy's doing.
Yeah.
Cause I'm too,
I always wonder like how much of of uh,
how much of a training camp and this is protected.
It's particularly important,
I guess in MMA.
How much of a training camp should be dedicated to strength and conditioning and
how much should be dedicated to skill work?
You know,
for me,
I,
for the last man standing,
I had a like a six months notice or something for the,
for the fight.
And uh,
my fight before that was with Wayne Barrett in New York and I just felt
physically too small when I fought him by moving,
that was the first time in my career where the guy that I weighed in against and
the guy got in the ring with were like two different people.
And uh,
they really bothered me mentally.
And like there were shots that he would hit me with that like didn't even land,
but he like hit me in the forearm and he'd be like pushing me across the ring.
And I really felt like too small and um,
you know,
I hit the weights and I was doing the high calorie things or whatever.
And I did the weights for a long,
long period of time.
And then,
um,
my coach stopped me about six,
six weeks out from the fight and was like,
you know,
more weights now you have to get your,
cause I was stiff and you know,
if you lift weights,
so you're sore all the time,
right?
Yeah.
You just saw her and you're,
every time you're muscle you're making it tighter and tighter and tighter.
And you know,
for speed,
for kickboxing,
especially in boxing,
it's about a technique and being loose and snap more so than like punching hard
and economy of movement too.
Right.
You gotta be able to be loose and yeah,
it's up.
It's about getting that punch,
the snap at the end and not trying to push through.
Right,
right,
right.
And,
uh,
you know,
I had a really good result with that,
with that camp.
Um,
and I felt like I was hitting harder,
obviously knocked out Simon,
you know,
so it was good.
Um,
but like now when I'm fighting so actively,
it's like I don't really have time to hit the weights and like bulk up or like
get that tight again.
You know?
So that's,
that's been an issue for me when you're fighting so consistently,
I'm sure that,
uh,
you know,
I'd be interested to see what Donald's Cerrone does when he's fighting so often,
if he has time,
because for me it was like,
okay,
get right back into camp.
You're right back where you are like the last,
you know,
five weeks or we're running all the time.
You're trying to get your speed and our agility,
but there's not a whole lot of strength training going on.
Yeah.
I talked to Diego Sanchez about that and Diego,
the way he would prepare for a flash.
Yes.
He just pulled out a cross and just started fucking screaming.
I didn't see that.
Somebody told me about that,
that they day and I'm like,
what the fuck this up?
You got to see it as like,
God,
I just saw that
he was telling me about it.
I didn't believe him.
And then I youtube.
Then I was like,
Holy Shit,
that's some,
there's not a mother fucker alive.
He believes in himself more than Diego Sanchez.
I mean you might believe in yourself as much,
but you are at 100% we were at 100% belief that mother fucker,
believe me,
I hit him when he was like walking out yelling yes or wherever,
but I hadn't seen where he like pulled out the cross and was like fighting
demons on the way to the ring.
That was fucking crazy.
The greatest moment for what that is.
Something smells.
So it's a lot of things.
No,
this is,
this is just a yes one.
This is great.
So he's like,
Diego's an interesting cat.
He's,
he's like,
he's very big on yoga.
He's very big on sensory deprivation tanks.
Like we talked in depth about sensory deprivation.
Fine.
He's got,
maybe it's the craziest one is it's a craziest Diego Sanchez Sanchez.
That's very subjective though.
All of his walk ins are crazy.
He,
uh,
no.
You know,
he's got a hook or some shit and he's like fucking fighting demons on the way
that it looks like some sort of a monk.
He's a big,
he's a big fan of optimizing everything he's got,
including his mental state.
Like he's really into like positive affirmations and positive thinking.
Yeah,
here it is.
Yeah.
This one.
So as he walks out,
like as he starts walking out towards the side,
pretty sure this got set up for it.
I'm like,
he's like hiding it or something and then Bam.
Yeah.
There it is.
Here's a fucking
look at this.
Oh,
see I don't,
I calling this
fight.
I don't believe,
I believe I was watching it at home,
so I got a chance to laugh.
I could laugh really hard yet.
So that's something right there.
That's if I had to see if I seen this.
Yeah,
it's Kenny Florian talking.
If I was there alive,
I most certainly would have started laughing.
Yeah.
But what I was going to say is that Diego,
what he does before camps is he would do only strength and conditioning.
No fitness,
no a striking training,
no grappling training,
no nothing.
Everything he would do leading up to his camp would be like weightlifting,
running like all physical physical shit.
Just get his body to the peak of condition.
Then he would start to taper off of that and then go into his skill set
training.
Right.
So they would do it like when he would actually do it six weeks for camp,
his six or it could be all wrestling,
all striking,
all Jujitsu.
That's ideally what I would do.
Except now it's like I only have six weeks between if I said I don't really have
time to do that right now.
He brought in Steve Maxwell for is Bj Penn fight.
And you know it was interesting because Steve said it was,
would almost be better if I didn't train him because Steve was like,
cause if I didn't train him he wouldn't be in as good a shape and they would
have been like a quicker fight.
Like he was.
So he was out class in that fight.
Like Bj was just lighting them up and because he was in such good shape,
he was able to take a tremendous amount of punishment.
I mean Bj dropped him just a couple minutes or so into the first round and then
just battered him for the rest of the fight until he eventually cut them with
that head kick and stopped him.
It's interesting too because I've heard and I kind of believe it is that your
Chin is improved with your,
the better shape here.
You heard that before like I would imagine,
I wonder why that is the,
well,
I think that when you're tired you're weak.
You know?
I mean,
um,
I remember I had a,
I find a kickboxing tournament.
It was a in Rhode Island above the waist,
kickboxing,
the old school days.
I want to use spinning heel kick knockouts.
Yeah.
Until I got,
it was pretty cool.
That was the taekwondo tournament.
But in a kickboxing tournament,
I fought three times in one night.
And um,
I won the first fight by knockout,
uh,
beat the shit out of the second guy and then have a long wait like,
like an hour plus four,
the third fight.
And I was exhausted and I wasn't in the best of shape,
wasn't,
you know,
wasn't that smart back then,
wasn't eating very good and uh,
I was really tired after the first round,
this fight and this guy hit me with a punch.
That really wasn't that.
It wasn't that big of a punch.
Like I remember seeing it on video,
hit me with a left hook and my legs just went,
take care.
We'll see you later.
They just stopped working and like,
I'm like any other time I'd be able to take that punch.
Like it doesn't make any sense.
It wasn't like sometimes you see a punch and you see your head snapped back and
go,
God damn,
you got cracked.
But this wasn't that.
It was just my body just was exhausted and if I was in better shape,
I know I would been able to take that better.
And you see guys that are in really good shape and it's very rare that they
can't recover from a couple hard shots.
Whereas it's at,
seems like everything is based on your vitality and if you are body is in really
good condition,
you can bounce back from things quicker.
Like Frankie Edgar's another perfect example.
I think a lot of it you have to chalk off to heart and will and determination.
You know like some guys like Frankie just has is fucking incredible.
We'll like,
you can't,
like,
he was like a dude who was a little dude who people have been fucking with him
since he's been,
he's a little guy.
He ain't having it.
You know,
he's kind of,
he's going to fucking kick your ass.
It doesn't matter how hard you hit him.
He's eventually gonna.
If,
if all fights went to a hundred rounds,
Frankie Edgar would never lose.
He would just keep going and keep going and keep going.
Eventually you get tired and he would beat your ass.
But I think one of the ways that he could absorb the kind of punishment that he
could absorb like against gray Maynard.
Remember those fights fucking insane.
Too Insane.
First rounds or gray had him out in both fights.
Great.
Cracked him.
I mean he's wobbling.
A lot of,
lot of referees would have stopped the fight.
He's going down to three times in the first round just getting wobbled.
Blood face swelling.
Second round he comes out and he winds around,
you know,
how's he doing?
It was just,
it was just insane shape.
His cardio is just so fucking good.
He can take it.
He bounces back from it.
He recovers quickly and then his cardio is so good that in the second round he's
back again.
Well then it's like the guys that lose their chin or they're just not in good
shape anymore or is it punishing an issue?
I think it's,
you know,
that's where we've all seen it.
Guys in the jail that have a certain amount of certain amount of times you could
punch that card until it's like it's over.
It's just doesn't work anymore.
Chucked described it to me once and he said,
the way it was described to him,
uh,
is that the doctor was telling him that at a certain point in time,
your brain recognizes that you're too tough for your own good.
So your brain knows when he gets tagged,
Oh,
this fucking dude is just going to start at absorbing punches again and we're
going to have to deal with all this damage.
Let's just shut off.
Right.
That makes sense.
That makes a lot of sense.
But last time this happened,
we just took a little nap and everything was fine.
Let's just do that again.
Let's just take a little nap.
I was like,
fuck this guy,
this asshole.
Once it's to go eat post doing this shit again.
Fuck your leg.
You got to wonder like,
what is that?
When that time is,
you know,
like when,
when do you,
uh,
when do you know was most fighters have think like,
you know what,
if I just have one more camp on a,
maybe I'll do eight weeks instead of six weeks.
It may be,
I'll clean my diet up and maybe I'll bring in a guy to work with me,
maybe on my defense a little bit more.
And maybe my strength and conditioning could be better than improve everything.
And I made it,
you got to know him in the camp though.
I mean,
if you're getting knocked out and sparring regularly,
you know,
if that's happening,
it has never happened with me in sparring and be like,
if that's,
if that's a thing happens in the gym,
like
how much confidence can you really have when you're walking into the rank?
Like two weeks ago he got knocked out.
She don't tell anybody.
Yeah.
So that's a regular occurrence,
regular occurrence and MMA.
A foreign script.
And when you fought her inner says he got knocked out apparently twice.
Yeah.
And you've seen the Marvin Eastman Travis Luder fight.
Um,
that was when Marvin got hit with this very strange punch.
It was like,
it was a decent punch,
but it was like at the very end of the punch and he just went out like he got
shot and I remember thinking,
wow,
that's kind of crazy.
Then we found that afterwards he got knocked out twice in camp,
like really recent,
like Tito and knocked him out with a knee and then someone had knocked him out,
uh,
got knocked out with like a take down attempt or something like that.
Like it was like two,
two in a row.
So like one didn't really recover from that.
Went back and got another one.
See that's the other thing.
It's like,
if are these,
is the,
is there just a number or is it like this guy got knocked out and I didn't do
the right things.
Didn't do the hyperbaric chamber.
You just didn't take time off.
You know what I mean?
Do you do that hyperbaric chamber?
Uh,
I used,
I've done it before and I did.
Uh,
I do like the,
the altitude tents at my house sleeping that,
yeah.
Do you get your lady to sleep in there with you?
Yeah.
She's not a big fan.
She asleep state.
It's like a giant tent.
And the uh,
the uh,
you know,
our nightstands a bed and everything fits in there and she just can't stand like
the smell of it cause it smells like you're sleeping in a tent.
All,
yeah.
I remember Bj Penn and one of the countdown shows,
it goes when you're going to sleep in a big plastic tent,
you know someone's going to get their ass kicked.
Yeah.
It's kind of fucked up.
Right.
Like sleeping in a big plastic tent just to,
but that's the only way
to mimic it.
They said that's actually the best way.
That's actually even better then training at altitude because training at
altitude kind of limits your workload.
Right.
Whereas you really want the recovery.
There's this place in Costa Mesa that would,
we used to go to before I got this hat and I probably will start going back to
it cause it was really good.
It was in,
it's called a a sent and the product is called [inaudible] and it's this
altitude chamber that um,
it looks like a jet plane cockpit.
Uh,
Ian uses it a lot of time.
Ian Mccall,
it was designed by the guy that invented the MRI machine and it's actually the
purpose behind it was to like cure diabetes or treat diabetes with circulation
problems or something,
but they can't,
they're in the process of getting it,
uh,
licensed or whatever to where they could was approved by the FDA or whatever
disease.
Huh?
Yeah.
Something about,
and they get people that have like,
you know,
people who have diabetes,
their feet turn purple because they're fucking bloods,
floods,
blood flows all fucked up that put people in this machine and they'll like,
after a couple of treatments,
like their feet get regular color again,
but the way it works is it,
it's uh,
it takes you to weigh higher altitude and like my at home goes to like thousand
feet.
This would go all the way to like 33,000 feet or some shit like Everest,
Everest.
And it goes up and down.
So like in a 20 minute session it goes,
you know,
based on what program it is,
like maybe Everest,
the back down to zero,
like a hundred times and 20 minutes like the while you're in there,
it's constantly dropping.
The pressure's filling up and dropping cause he's the guy who found that your
body goes through more of a metabolic change during the,
the change of altitude as opposed to like what did we've known as you go and you
stay there for eight hours or however long and then he'd come back down to
train.
So this is constantly going up and down,
up and down,
up and down and your body's like,
what the fuck?
What the fuck?
And that's supposed to create more red blood cells are particularly really,
can you get one of those for a gym?
You can,
they have,
I think there's like 15 in the u s um,
crazy expensive,
I'm sure.
Sure.
Yeah,
I think you could,
you could definitely do that.
You could hit up.
Ah,
there it goes to Mesa.
Yeah.
Demo and say,
is there a demo for this?
They have a video,
Jamie,
probably that looks,
are you going to launch into the fucking universe in that thing?
A lot of a lot of fighters use it.
A lot of triathletes are using it on there.
Uh,
it's,
it's really good stuff.
I just stopped doing it because it was so with my schedule and training here and
there and everywhere else.
Driving all the way to Costa Mesa and back everyday was tough,
but if you had one in the yard though,
probably jumping that pitch out every day.
I'd sleep in that thing.
Cranked this up.
Jimmy,
let me hear this.
I want to be what they have to say.
Hi.
Creating lower pressure and thinner air.
Just like you get on a day of skiing up in Aspen.
Athletes get an increase in vo two Max or our field of vision.
Quicker reaction.
Endurance.
How
the seat back people say the body's response is to increase its blood volume,
but that they still haven't studied the effects enough to save for sure.
I decided to get into the thing and try out a typical session,
not going to get injured in this
pussy.
Get in there like your ears will pop,
like shed,
like really fucking hard.
It's like you have to get,
it takes like four or five sessions to get used to it.
Wow.
But uh,
yeah,
my coach would notice a big difference.
And like the biggest difference that I noticed from that,
from using now,
sutent was like the fog.
Oh flick sparring or being in a fight,
like all of the,
everything kind of slowed down.
Like it just seemed like more focused.
I'd find myself like checking out the guy's tattoos
and like my coach would notice a big difference,
like two sessions in there and he be like,
you've been using that machine on?
And like,
yeah.
Really?
Wow.
Cause I mean,
as a smoker,
Joe,
I gotta take care of every,
you know,
I got to do everything I can.
So that was,
that was a regular part of like six or seven of my fights.
I was going down there.
No shit man,
you got to get back in there dude.
Yeah,
I really do.
Got To fall.
We'll get his,
his ears are popping body.
Yes.
So you're constantly and they're just popping her as popping as pop Norris.
Oh,
this is fucking cool.
Fucking cap.
It'll crush the shooting off
the water bottle.
Just like,
like a gorilla smushed it.
Yeah,
baby.
Use The pod and believe it helps.
Some university research has been,
I literally loved about it is there was only like 12 I think in the u s like I
knew when I was in there that
my opponent wasn't,
wasn't using that shit.
Right.
I mean like,
yeah,
this is,
that's what people feel like you can do steroids
essentially.
Yeah.
Did we talk about the Cryo chamber last time you were there?
You,
you referred me.
I went down to it.
When did you was cool.
It was real cool.
Does it come out here now?
Oh,
there's one right down the street I could live in and that shit.
How many times today have you been in the I haven't been,
yeah,
just opened.
It hasn't even had like a hard opening yet.
They just done a soft opening.
Same company though.
Cryo healthcare is that,
that's where he went wrong.
Yeah.
That's amazing,
isn't it?
It was really cool.
Cold as fuck.
But when you get out,
don't you feel like you could jump over the moon yet?
It was like fucking,
I try to describe it in text and I was like,
I didn't,
so I'm fucking write it.
I'll be like,
when you're in there and I would like take a deep breath.
It's almost like a head rush,
like fucking cold air going in.
It was,
it was almost like a whippet.
It was cool.
The whole thing.
It was fucking cool.
It was cool at night.
Next on my list.
I want to try one of those,
uh,
the float labs.
Tell me when you tell me when you can use mine at my house.
Yeah,
come on over dude.
You tell me when.
All right.
Whenever,
whenever you're free,
we'll listen.
Let's,
let's set up a date soon and,
uh,
come on over the house.
You could have dinner and uh,
I'll leave you down there for a few hours.
Cool.
And come on up and you'll,
you'll freak out.
That's awesome.
What,
what did,
I mean,
my buddy told me about it and it's like a hallucinogenic kind of thing or,
well,
sorta not.
I've heard people like using it for training.
So yeah.
What's great for training,
you know,
it's great for problem solving too.
Uh,
I use it for like,
if I have a joke that I'm working on,
it's not working well,
I'll go in there and I'll sort it out.
I'm like,
Oh fuck.
It's gotta be an angle for this joke.
Like I could sit down and look at a keyboard and maybe think about it,
but I feel like my mind has more resources when I'm in the tank.
And the reason being is that the idea of the sensory deprivation tank was
created by this guy named John Lilly.
John Lilly was just really nutty dude.
He was a psychedelic pioneer,
uh,
esteemed professor and intellectual.
It was a pioneer interspecies communication,
did a lot of research with dolphin communication,
did a lot of drugs and a lot of LSD,
lot of ketamine.
And one of his things was he was trying to figure out how to separate the mind
from the influence of the body.
He was thinking that there's like,
oh my neck hurts.
Like,
oh,
I got to Fart.
You know,
like all these different things that are going on in your body that are
distracting the mind.
How could I get away from that?
And he came up with a bunch of different solutions.
One of them was,
you've seen that movie altered states ever seen him?
It's really stupid,
man.
It was great in the 80s when I saw it when I was a kid,
I was like,
this movie's Great.
And it's one of the movies you watch again when you're 40.
Go without spooking.
So many movies don't hold up.
Yeah,
that's weird though.
It's one of them.
It does not hold up.
But,
um,
it was based on John Lilly.
That's how all the van Damme movies where,
Oh yeah,
I would like kickbox here where like changed my life,
you know,
and it's solid a couple of months ago and I was like,
what
have you seen that little kid before we get into the sensory deprivation tank?
Have you seen that little kid doing the Bruce Lee Nimchuk scene?
Yeah,
I saw that shit.
Fucking amazing.
Four years old.
Watch this.
Look at this little kid.
He's wearing a Bruce Lee outfit from the game of death and he's gotten nunchucks
just like Bruce Lee's and he was,
he's doing it in sync to Bruce Lee behind him.
Like
he's doing the total noon,
chuck move skillful as fuck.
He's five years old and he's doing everything exactly the way Bruce is doing it
on the screen behind them.
So cool.
Amazing.
It's so good.
Like first of all,
this kid definitely can't read yet,
right?
These five,
it probably hasn't even been to school yet.
Maybe a little bit of kindergarten,
you know,
pre k maybe she's got no information in his head other than this Bruce Lee
scene.
That's the key.
That's the key and like,
you know,
and then by the time kids 12 they'll be 500 people in his life to tell them to
be realistic and like shoot him down.
Every imaginative thing that he has in his fucking head.
When I look at my kids just,
I love this.
This makes me really happy when I see that.
Yeah,
me too man.
Dana white posted this video the other day of a little girl hitting the mitts.
Find that video on Dana White's Instagram.
It's this little girl,
she looks like she's maybe like six or seven years old and she's hitting the
meds and fucking technique is on point.
She's blocking and roll in and you know,
no kicks.
Just punches.
But like God damn that tap out commercial came out a couple of years ago when
they had those two kids.
Two little [inaudible].
I'm doing all that shit too.
This is the future.
And still,
here's the video.
Watch this.
I saw this.
Yeah.
Dope.
I mean,
come on man.
This is fucking bad at.
Look at the technique.
Look at our footwork,
the movie.
Look at the fucking ducking.
Come on man,
every time she's throwing these punches or hands are in the right position.
I'm so impressed with this.
That's impressive.
Pr,
you know that girls can grow up to be a psycho.
You don't want to date her,
but I know they'll do it.
That one
somehow has to be some level of where the fight sit stop and you're like,
okay,
you know,
I don't want the girl to be able to like take it to the next level.
You're arguing and then starts beating your ass.
Like it's not cool.
Yeah.
Like if you date and Ronda rousing,
she mounts you go listen bitch,
you got to get off.
May Lead my arm alone.
Um,
so the sensory deprivation tank,
the get back to that,
the way he first did it was like a scuba helmet.
He came up with a way to hook up a scuba helmet with like these underarm
harnesses so that you kind of,
you're suspended by the air and the scuba helmet and you know,
kind of like floats your body.
And then eventually you forget about the school,
but helmet and then somewhere along the lines he realized if you just
had water that was filled with salt,
that you would just float in it.
Sort of like the dead.
Say you ever see those videos of the people that go to the Dead Sea?
No,
I'd heard about this.
I hope he didn't explain to me cause she float on the salt.
So it's packed full of salt.
But at the salt lake is buoyant.
That salt is as long as you continue to cycle the water,
the water,
my pump goes on every morning,
it's on a timer.
So I get five o'clock in the morning.
Like sometimes I'm up real early and I'll hear blue coming down from the
basement and that's the pump kicking on automatically.
And the,
the water cycles through this series of filters is huge.
Spa filters with like the way that guy crash down at the float lab,
uh,
in Venice is a mad genius.
This guy has done.
Like when he first came around,
I found out about him through a guy who used to repair tanks for this company
called Samadhi.
Samadhi is the first company that I bought a tank farm and they were actually in
business with Lily Lily's first tank.
But one of his first tasks was a Samadhi and um,
he kind of taught them how to put it together and manufacture it.
And then this guy crash,
he's just crazy and he's just very technically oriented and he just took it to a
totally new level.
He uses ozone to filter out the water and he has oxygen pumped into the chamber.
He made the chamber walls real thick and insulated so it retains heat,
no sound.
It keeps the heat stable and they're much tall.
His,
his tanks are seven feet tall and six feet wide and nine feet long.
I mean he's,
he's a master.
The guy just figured it out and so this a pump kicks on and it goes through all
the water cycles,
all the water.
So the water doesn't crystallize.
Cause if you let it sit,
the salt will eventually crystallize.
And then I've done that before accidentally.
The power,
uh,
kicked off and I didn't know about it like a,
a circuit blue and I had these rocks,
these giant like crystals in the,
in the uh,
water.
Just because the salt,
it's sort of congealed cause there was no heat in it any more to keep it,
keep it warm.
But as long as the water keeps cycling and as long as the water stays at a high
temperature,
which is around,
you want to keep it,
mine's at 94 degrees,
which is about the same as the cell surface of your skin.
Oh,
okay.
So then when you lie in it,
you don't feel the water really because the water's the same temperature as your
skin.
That's the goal.
If it's too hot,
you'll start to sweat.
It was too cold,
you'll feel cold.
But if you get a chest and that goldilocks zone,
then once you relax,
you don't feel the water and half of your body.
Like,
like say like if you cut a person half from the top of their head,
like sideways,
like everything above your nipples is like,
that's what it looks like right there.
Perfect example.
Huh?
So,
uh,
in this image that we're looking at right here,
this guy's floating in the water and uh,
it's just because the salt,
there's a mine has minds a little bit bigger than this tanks and mine is a
thousand pounds of salt in it.
It's all Epsom salts too,
which is really good for your body.
Like when I'm real sore,
I take Epsom salt baths the great for you it's something about the amount of
salt in your body or magnesium.
Yeah,
because we use it to,
to cut weight sometimes the last couple of ounces or pounds,
he can't get a,
also if you drink it in water,
you will shoot diarrhea out of your ass hole in a way that you've probably never
experienced in your life.
It's like a way of a top 10 list of things that need to do,
but that,
well,
people do it shoot diarrhea your ass like nobody's business.
It's like a a way to do an enema.
Yeah,
it's,
yeah.
Yeah.
You can,
you drink a little bit of,
I mean it's not much.
He'd like a couple of tablespoons in a glass of water and you just,
you go,
oh,
he just run to the bathroom.
There's something about that salt just gets in there and scrubs the inside of
your colon and anything that's stuck that's gotta be pretty healthy actually.
Maybe,
maybe not.
Could be not good at all.
Have you done a colonic?
Yeah,
I haven't either.
I don't know about that.
I hear mixed things.
I hear it's,
I'm sure people on Twitter with,
tell me now about how great it is or how awful it is.
Somebody,
there's another thing.
Somebody did that for the ultimate fighter to cut weight on one of the episodes.
That was game Ruger.
Yeah.
He probably wanted something up his ass.
I'm just kidding,
Gabe.
It's,
it's supposed to be good for you and I in some ways.
No,
he's not.
Before we get on the show,
before we started,
Joe Rogan was talking about you gave,
he said you were in the shit like that.
I'm just putting it out there.
I didn't say that.
Making shit up.
If you gave her any things in your ass.
Some dudes are straight as fuck.
They just like things in their ass.
That's up to you folks.
It's all on you.
It's okay.
No judgment.
Um,
but the Kalanick thing,
I have a friend who did it and he said,
dude,
he's like the fucking pianos were coming out of my ass.
He goes,
I was finding things that I ate when I was a kid.
I was like,
he was,
he said there was a pipe that was coming out like,
you know,
it's attached and you could see all the things that were coming out of your ass
and the like,
the lady was pointing out his diet and she was like,
you know,
oh you need more fiber.
And he's like,
it was fucking tree trunks are coming out of his ass and bark and tennis balls.
He said,
it's just ridiculous.
And you're looking through a two.
But this water with all the,
you know,
the particles.
How much weight did he dropped his,
you know,
I don't think Gabe got,
that's the thing about taking a shit.
Shit's don't weigh that much.
You know,
pisses way heavier.
Like if you have to take a leak to gain weight.
Like we learned that in wrestling.
Like a guy took a shit and he was like,
dude,
I just took a mass for shit.
I bet he lost a pound
ounce.
Yeah.
Shit is not heavy for some strange reason,
but like if you're sick and you have diarrhea or whatever,
I end up like dehydrated like a mother fucker.
You're driving a lot of weight.
That's dangerous.
Yeah.
That's one of the ways people die from dehydration.
When the primary ways people die from dehydration is diarrhea.
It's very dangerous.
Like certain diseases where where people just get wrap,
massive diarrhea that winds up.
It's,
it's one of the causes of death.
It's because your body just gets so dehydrated.
Your electrolytes drops so low.
Your heart function doesn't work properly.
It's a shitty conversation.
Is it French shitting calm?
He had a big smile on his face and he said that he was sending it up.
So it's a float lab.
The float lab would,
the tank does is,
um,
first of all,
it's real relaxing.
Like your muscles loosen up because you're floating.
You like in that no gravity state like you saw in that picture.
Yeah.
Everything is like a,
you know,
nothing's pulling on it.
Like even here when we're sitting here,
you know,
gravity's pulling down your spine and there everything seems to like lengthen up
and relax.
And when I get out of it,
I feel so loose.
I just feel just relaxed.
And the magnesium,
the salt absorbs into your skin and it's Epsom salt.
So it's an excellent source of magnesium,
really healthy for your body,
for muscle growth and development.
And when you're in there,
you don't have any influence,
uh,
of your body.
Like you're not the,
sometimes you get like an itch,
but that's really just your body fucking with you because your body's like,
hey,
there's nothing going on here.
I don't feel anything.
My nose itches.
And you like wouldn't telling you is such a mind fuck yeah.
You know,
you just started with don't scratch whatever you do.
But,
so the idea is that someone told me that it's simulates the same feeling as
being in the womb or something.
Yeah,
I've heard that too.
I wonder,
but if your mother's yelling at your father and smoking cigarettes events
different,
Huh?
I think that,
um,
what it,
what it does is it gives you a relaxation state that's unachievable without the
tank because there's no news,
nothing touch.
It's an environment that is completely alien to the earth.
When you lie in that thing,
you literally don't see anything.
You don't feel anything and you're floating,
which means you feel like you're weightless.
You feel like you're flying.
It gives you the feeling,
the impression of like,
of like moving through space.
Like you're flying through space.
It's real weird,
right?
When you're going in there,
do you feel like different or is there like a panic that happens or like,
you know,
um,
you can,
some people get a little claustrophobic,
but you just gotta relax.
Nothing's going to happen.
It's just like laying on the ground.
It's just the door.
The door doesn't have a latch,
you just push.
It opens,
appeasing.
You know,
I've done it so many times,
I don't have the panic feeling anymore,
but there's a weirdness to it.
Definitely.
You climb in there and I,
you know,
I always,
I squeegee it because a,
there's always like a little bit of condensation on the roof,
uh,
the,
inside the ceiling rather of the tank.
So I squeezed you that away.
Otherwise it'll drip down your face while you're,
while you're in there,
which is annoying.
And then once,
uh,
once I've done squeezed unit,
I shut the door.
I'm like,
can we go?
I just lay back and,
and flow.
Yeah.
And you will definitely,
once you do it for a while,
you will definitely have trippy experiences in there.
He definitely have like some sort of strange psychedelic experiences that
happen,
but also real good for sorting out things.
Like say if you,
man,
I gotta get my shit together.
Let me go in there and think about my life.
You'll go in there and you'll go,
you know,
I gotta stop doing this or I got to stop hanging around with this person or I
got to do more of that,
or I'm slacking off in this area.
Like it's almost like a seminar on your life.
And if I have a like a Jujitsu moves,
it's great for Jujitsu moves.
Like I'll drill Jujitsu moves in my mind and the way I'll do it is aligning the
tank and I'll go over positions as if they're happening in real life.
Like I'll start off slow and like,
you know like if you were doing like flow drilling or something like that,
like I'll start off like I'll like say for instance,
I'll do like a half guard sweep.
Like,
I'll start off in half guard,
I'll scoot my hips this side,
a fight for the under hook,
I'll get the,
I'll get the grip,
a pull guy in,
I'll trip the leg up,
I sweep,
I get on top and then I'll,
I'll do it as if it was a drill,
like if you're performing a drill,
but I'll do it all completely in my head and I'll go over the motions first
slowly and then I'll do it fast and then I'll go over it and then I'll do it.
Like I'll,
I'll,
I'll recreate like the violence of it,
like the explosion of it in my head.
I'll recreate the resistance and then once I get like one drill down,
then I'll have counters to the drill.
Like I'll go into it but I'll lose a position and now I have to,
you know,
reestablish another position.
And when you do that,
like that kind of mental training really shows up in,
in the,
in the gym.
Like it really recreates in the gym.
And I would imagine it'd be the same as striking out.
Imagine it'd be the same with tennis,
with anything.
I think,
I think they've shown that recreation and visualization is as much of a factor
in the development and growth as actual training.
Yes.
Oh absolutely.
Absolutely.
Do you do stuff like that?
Yeah,
I'm into that stuff.
I know you're working with Vinny shoreman there,
right?
Vinnie is going to come on the podcast.
I've been talking to Ian about it.
We're going to work this out.
Yeah.
He's coming to to uh,
and June.
He's going to be here for a couple of weeks doing like seminars and stuff.
So
yeah.
You were saying the last time you were here that he helped you,
like what do,
what do you guys do like and how often you,
we've done a lot of stuff and then now it's like,
it's,
it seems to be every,
every time I talked to him it's like a new thing that,
uh,
he comes up with it,
it just,
he's helped me so much in my life.
It's not even,
I don't even know if it's even about fighting anymore.
I was just stuff that he's,
uh,
you know,
he's done hypnosis on me.
He's got me to the point now where it's a,
we call it trance.
It's not even hypnosis,
but like,
he can start talking to me a certain way and I'm already in a different thing.
When I get off the phone with them,
my mind's just going insane based off the conversations we had.
It's real.
It's really weird.
It's,
it's amazing guy.
Really good guy.
I can't wait to talk to him.
The mind is a motherfucker,
isn't it?
Yeah,
it's really,
it really is that stuff you were just talking about right now.
So it's really interesting to me.
Uh,
I've done that with,
with my fights,
you know,
like,
uh,
you know,
watching a fight,
if I would explain it even like blocking leg kicks,
you know,
uh,
when you can visualize it happening and your reaction to it,
you know,
in your head without actually seeing it or that actually doing it,
I think it make,
it plays it out to be so real is a good example.
So,
uh,
one thing we do is,
I'll focus when I,
when I sign a fighter,
we get booked for a certain date.
About four or five weeks out all the time.
When I wake up in the morning,
when I'm sitting on the toilet,
anytime I'm alone,
I'll,
uh,
think about 15 minutes after I won the fight.
15 minutes after I'm thinking is high def as possible.
When the first time I'm doing it,
it's not very high death by the end it's like,
it's so real.
I could smell,
smell the room,
I can feel the chair I'm sitting in.
It can see the,
the my coaches faces.
Who else is in there?
What uh,
what they're saying to me,
how I feel about myself.
And the idea behind it is if,
if,
um,
if you focus on 15 minutes after you've won and you do it over a period of time,
it becomes so real in your head that it's like it already happened and if it's
already happened,
how could you possibly have anxiety about something that your mind thinks
already happened?
You know?
Does that make sense?
Is there a possibility that you know,
that feeling that you get,
um,
I don't know if you've experienced this.
Probably you probably have where you didn't get up for a fight because you
thought that you're going to kick this guy's ass pretty easy,
so you weren't nervous.
And then when you got in there,
you felt like off like you did.
You weren't performing the way.
Like you would be like,
say if you fought a guy like art Tim Lebbon who you know,
top of the food chain,
you're,
you're going to be on your toes.
You know,
you're going to be ready.
Whereas you're going in there,
you're like,
I'm going to kick this fucking guy's ass.
And mean you go in there and you like,
it just seems like damn,
like this is not,
I'm not firing.
Right.
It's not,
is that possible?
I mean,
deviation of anxiety cause like,
I don't know about that.
I think that it could be,
I think that that what you're talking about is something that is ultimately
helped me with a lot because my,
my problem is I,
one of my problems,
so many problems.
One big problem is I always do poorly in that situation.
When I'm,
when I'm the favorite,
I have a hard time.
Um,
it's not that I don't train hard for it,
it's just something about,
uh,
I always,
I'm that guy that rises to the occasion of the three fights in one night where
it's,
you know,
how the could you,
it's three rematches in two guys beat you.
And that's,
that's when I do really well.
It's right.
No one expects you to win is when,
when I really rise to the occasion when,
when,
when people start telling me that it's an easy fighter,
that it's,
you know,
I'm the favorite or whatever.
I just really try and shut that out and try and convince myself that,
you know,
he's going to kill me and he's a really bad guy.
I don't know if it's about not getting up for the fighter,
if it's,
uh,
you know,
you just take the guy lightly or what it is,
but I've always had issues with that in the past.
A lot of people have issues with that.
Taking a guy in
lightly is a huge problem and it's a real common in,
in you see it in a fight,
like maybe when a guy's the favorite.
Like I'm not necessarily saying that this was the case in the cub,
Swanson Max Holloway fight.
Did you see that fight?
Great fucking fight.
Max Holloway,
man,
that motherfucker looked good in that fight.
God Damn was a amazing performance by Holloway.
But Cub Swanson was a big favorite lead leading into that fight and he just
couldn't get off,
just did not seem like he get off.
And um,
I think there's probably a few issues with the way he was training.
He was doing a lot of um,
boxing specific training and even had a,
a famous boxing coach.
Um,
I forget his name.
Diaz in his corner.
Yep.
Uh,
no,
that's the guy from Miami.
Yeah,
no,
this was the guy that trains,
um,
uh,
Tim Bradley.
He works with a lot of,
uh,
I forgot it doesn't matter.
Point is the guy was giving him like boxing instruction in the corner.
And I'm like,
he's dealing with a guy that's kicking him,
throwing the elbows and flying knees and spinning back,
kicks his way.
Like walk off.
You know,
like this is,
you got the wrong guy here man,
you need,
you need a fucking Matt Hume type character that's telling you like MMA specific
shit to do.
I'm so,
there's probably some technical issues with the way he approached the fight but
also just didn't seem like if you saw him against like other fighters like,
like Jeremy Stevens who's a fucking murderer,
you know,
he's,
he's fighting,
he's a murderer,
he's fighting another murderer.
These two guys are dangerous as fuck.
You know,
he is a sharp as shit cause it's just deadly dangerous fight.
Whereas Max Holloway,
you know,
he had beaten some real good guys,
but he was thought to be like a notch below cup and comp just couldn't fucking
put it together.
And you,
you know,
you got to say,
well it was definitely a case of Holloway rising to the occasion,
fought better than they ever fought before.
You can't take nothing away from him,
but when you look at cub,
just didn't look,
didn't look right,
just couldn't.
And you've got to wonder how much of that is him coming into that fight as a
prohibitive favorite.
Like I think it was like three,
four to one favorite.
Well,
it's like one guy is,
you know,
this is,
this is my big shot.
This is everything.
You know,
he's focused on it.
Like hundred percent of the other guys that go,
this is another fight.
It's still a serious fight.
I know it's,
I still got to take it seriously,
but the other guy is like going for greatness in your,
you know,
it's,
it's a,
it's a weird balancing act,
you know,
so much of fighting is mental.
Um,
you can have a phenomenal camp and that lasts two hours before you walk out
there.
Couldn't come blow it all,
you know?
So that's why I work with Vinny and uh,
you know,
we're,
we're always finding new things to work on and you know,
I'm far from perfect,
but I feel like my game is,
has come a long way since I started work or work
with them.
Yeah,
I really think we discussed this.
I really think that mental coach is going to be just as important as having a
striking coach.
Just as important as having a grappling coach.
I mean,
you're going to have to have a mental coach.
It's going to be just like you have guys have strength and guys,
you know that they work with on a regular basis.
You're going to have some sort of a mental coach that you work with on a regular
basis.
I think it's,
it's going to be a really,
you know,
it's going to be the next big thing or pretty soon.
I think so till it doesn't though.
I hope I stick to just me.
No one else.
You.
Well,
I would wonder if someone could do it where they have a microphone that pumps
into a tank where a,
you lie in the sensory deprivation tank and it's miked up,
which should be very easy to do and as you're lying in there,
like crash has developed this system where he actually has a screen that's in
front of you as you lie down,
so as you're floating,
this screen is floating above your head and it's so low in its light emissions
that you can't see the edge.
You don't see the border of the screen,
you just see the images,
but because you're in a,
you're in an environment that has no light in it at all other than the screen.
It's like this.
These images are floating in the sky in front of your face and in doing so he
believes because you have no distractions,
like no physical distractions.
You're not feeling the weight,
you're not feeling gravity,
you're not feeling sensory input,
you're not judging space around you,
you just getting the images.
You'll learn things quicker because your body will have no,
no resources that it's demanding of the,
of the mind.
What's the,
what's the,
what's on the screen?
Different documentaries.
Different instructionals like he's got one that they're working with.
I think his idea is that like sports specific stuff like golf,
like that you would absorb like information,
like how like the rotation of the hips and you know,
especially doing things from a first person perspective on a and showing shows
color lay in there and do like straight Djj stuff.
Yeah.
Like a week.
Work on your half guard.
The get ups.
Yeah.
I want you to come down to 10th planet and uh,
and learn some shit from Eddie Bravo two with your long legs.
I'd love like learning some,
uh,
some guard stuff.
Even just learning how to hold on to guys in a way where they can't,
they can't hit you and they're not going to be able to get up or you'll get
standups better,
which is a legit strategy and Nma as long as they have standups.
I don't know.
I don't agree with standups,
honestly.
Think they should be removed from fighting because I think that if you're going
to have MMA,
uh,
if you've got a guy that can hold you down for five minutes,
that's,
that's what it is.
You get in five minutes from now and you're gonna be able to get up and every
fight starts,
every round starts standing,
you know?
So you think that people should win fights based on not fighting like,
no,
but my like,
I just don't think that you should win a fight by your goal and the fight is
just to nullify the fight.
I think if I can stop this fight from happening for three,
three,
five minute rounds that I,
when I understand what you're saying,
but I think that if a guy can take you down and hold you and control you,
he's kicking your ass.
Even if he's not beating you up the way you would be to guide up.
Like if you had your druthers,
you'd forced guys to stand with you and you'd light them up.
You have a giant over 99.9% of the planet in MMA when it comes to kickboxing,
your,
I mean,
your ideal world is like get these guys to just stand with you.
Let's,
hey,
let's make an agreement.
Fuck shooting.
No takedowns let's just throw,
you know you're going to have a giant advantage.
And so other guys would say,
listen,
I'm just making an agreement.
No,
no kickboxing.
Let's just,
uh,
let's just see who's the better grappler.
You'd be like,
get the fuck Outta here.
But for a guy like Ben Asker and that would be a really good agreement.
Right,
right.
Because he could take down most guys,
he fights vanaskie her and gets a hold of guys like,
like Douglas Lema,
fucking killer.
Kickboxer dangerous motherfucker been astronauts,
just rag dolls ragdoll some tosses him to the ground and in can do that
consistently.
So for a guy like that,
why would you,
why would a guy like that want to stand up?
He could,
he could grab a hold of you and you can't stop him from taking you down if you
watch like some aspirins fights.
By the time it gets to the third and fourth round,
his opponents were like,
fuck,
this guy's going to take me down again and I can't do shit.
Well that's a fight and he is fighting,
but he's fighting you his way.
He's not,
he doesn't have the kind of snap to his punches or kicks that you do.
It doesn't have the kind of arsenal of attacks when it comes to striking that a
guy like you does,
but when it comes to holding motherfuckers down and giving them nuggies punched
him in the face and they can't do shit about it.
That's his world.
And I think for fighting to be realistic,
you've got to have guys like that as well.
Like a lot of people didn't like Matt Brown and Johnny Hendricks the last fight.
I loved it.
I didn't love it because I wanted Matt Brown to lose.
I loved it from a technical standpoint because you got a guy like Johnny
Hendricks who was a decorated all American wrestler and that just shows you,
this is what happens when you fight a high level wrestler like Hendricks.
It's on point.
The motherfucker is going to take you down whenever he wants to and he's going
to be on top and you're going to be eating shit sandwiches and that's just the
way it goes as the wake.
And that's a real fight.
If you want to fight in MMA,
that's a real fight.
Now if Hendrickson Matt Brown fought in the boy tie fight,
it was a,
it'd be a completely different fight if Hendrix couldn't shoot for the take down
whenever he was in trouble and he got stuck or especially forget Moy Tai,
take up more glory rules.
We've going only grapple for five seconds where you can only clinch for five
seconds.
Then you've got a completely different fight and then you got to fight where
Matt Brown is just throwing elbows and kicks and knees and punches and just
keeps coming at you.
Is Not afraid to throw a flying knee cause he's not worried about getting taken
down.
He's not worried about just blasting you with leg kicks cause you can't grab his
legs.
You can't trip them and throw them down and get on top of them.
You can only kickbox with them.
Yeah,
I agree.
But I think that if you take the guy down and you just lay on top of him that
it's somebody's responsibility to,
for the love of God to do something and stand them up.
Or like,
you know,
my last fight,
you know the referees like you guys gotta improve positioner I'm gonna stand you
up.
I'm like,
okay,
yes,
Tammy up bitch,
you gonna stand you up.
All right,
we're gonna stand you up and I'll make,
are you going to fucking stand a sub or not?
Well you know,
he's clenching against the fence.
I mean I think I agree with you and that's,
I mean the way I obviously have to look at it is that I have to be able to stop
him from doing that.
I mean that's,
that's the reality is I can't allow these guys to continuously do this because
let's face it,
that's what people are going to do.
But I think that on the scorecards,
if one guy gets dropped and then lays on top of you for three minutes and then
you know who's wins that round,
the guy that drops the other guy cleaned with a punch or the one that lays on
top of my specific,
but if you want to judge me,
mine's the only one that matters shows
especially that one,
right?
If you want to judge damage for sure you won that round and you won that fight
if you want a judge damage.
But the problem is they don't just judge damage.
They also judge control.
He didn't do anything to you once he got you down.
I mean he stayed active but there was no moments where like you were in trouble
the moment where you hit him.
And dropped him was the most significant moment of that fight by far because it
dude's consciousness was wobbled,
his fucking legs gave out.
He was on Queer Street,
he was in deep shit.
But he was able to clinch up with you and it was able to turn it to a grappling
match and survive.
So when you look at it damage wise.
Yeah,
that was the closest to him losing consciousness for sure.
But MMA is about a bunch of shit.
It's about controlling the moments.
See I personally think that pride had it right.
I agree.
I think they had the best rules.
I like the yellow cards.
I don't like,
I don't like fighters being punished financially.
I don't agree with the yellow cards as far as like taking 10% of your purse.
I think that's bullshit.
But I do think that some stalling,
like if guys are just running away and they're not doing something you,
you should be able to penalize them.
Maybe a percentage of a point,
like maybe instead of a full point deduction,
maybe it's a percentage of a point and all that.
Cause I think the scoring system 10 point scoring system is retarded.
The only reason it exists is because it exists for boxing.
Right.
And it kind of works for boxing.
It's a good system for boxing.
But when you have MMA and you're dealing with takedowns submission attempts,
kicks,
punches,
elbows,
knees,
I mean most people,
uh,
if you don't know,
if you've never watched Moyie Thai muy Thais judged very different than MMA and
a very different than boxing.
Like the clinch in [inaudible] is very important.
Controlling the clinch is one of the most important things.
Kicks are judged very highly in Moy Tai.
I think the problem with when we tie in the U S is that it's refereed by Steve
Mazzagatti.
Other people that do,
you know,
the same guys,
like if you watch a Muy Thai fight and Thailand,
the referee actually knows what's going on in the clinch.
And if there's not shit going on in the clinch,
they break you.
But Steve Mazzagatti,
we'll let you hold on me.
When I fought Simon,
he was like,
I was talking to Steve and Steve,
you can break us and he would just hold me against the rope for long,
long,
long period of time.
Right.
And he does that consistently.
So you need like Apollo Tosha guy or something like that.
Like someone who's been maybe not him.
I laugh all
the time,
you know what I'm saying?
I do next topic.
He's always been nice to me.
But you know what I'm saying?
Like someone who's maybe competed in white tie,
someone that's been around for a long time,
it goes in anything.
It's the people that are judging and the people that are referring in any sport,
you know,
should,
should know what the hell they're doing.
You know?
And one question,
what's important in any sport,
you know,
and uh,
like with Mike sit here and complain about my fight and really don't care.
But uh,
who was the referee?
Uh,
uh,
Bill Beltran.
Yeah,
he's good.
He's good.
Mike's good.
Mike's very good.
But three judges,
three different scorecards.
Mm.
That's a problem.
One of the one deciding score code all three rounds to my opponent.
That doesn't make sense.
Yeah,
it doesn't make sense.
That's incorrect.
What frustrates me about that situation,
it's like I have to look at my record and deal with it and I have to deal with
the consequences pay wise,
sponsor wise,
whatever.
You know,
what if I don't do my job regardless of anybody else,
but if I don't do my job,
there's consequences.
But,
and,
and all of that athletic commissions on a regular basis,
there's constantly mistakes and there's constantly people not doing their jobs
correctly and there's no consequences for them.
There's never any retro,
there's never anything but the fighter that,
you know has to deal with it.
Yeah.
It was a good Manny Pacquiao fight with Timothy Bradley.
What was the consequence to that?
Well,
what,
and one of the women were happened,
one of the women who was a very controversial judge in that stop judging,
uh,
because of that fight.
And,
uh,
there was one other fight that she judged as well,
where there was a lot of speculation about
whether or not there was corruption involved.
And when just in competence,
which is just speculation,
no one knows.
But she had a series of like really ridiculous scorecards on championship level
fights where you're like,
what the fuck?
Like how is this like,
first of all,
especially in boxing,
boxing has been around for fucking hundreds of years.
We're not talking about MMA where there's just really not that many people that
are really good practitioners and all the various martial arts at understand all
the different positions.
There's,
when you watch him boxing,
it's pretty goddamn clearcut punching.
There's movement,
there's defense.
That's it.
That's all it is.
Like this,
uh,
this Floyd Mayweather fight.
What did you think about that fight?
Uh,
I thought it was exactly what I thought it was going to happen.
Me,
Tina.
I mean,
uh,
and I'm not,
the person that hates,
I mean was,
it drives me nuts as how many people have no clue about boxing and are all over
like the Internet now complaining and saying that their side of the story,
the fact is Mayweather is the best in the world of defense and not getting hit
and hitting you and not getting hit.
And the reason this fight was so interested in everybody as they thought that
Manny Pacquiao was going to do something different than what had happened in 48
other maybe where there's fights and it didn't happen and everyone's pissed off
at Mayweather about it.
It's like that's the same shit he's done his whole career.
What?
You should be mad at Petco.
But the,
uh,
the scorecards were messed up.
They miss mark this scorecards,
you saw this,
that they,
uh,
they thought that may,
whether it was in
the blue corner or the red corner or whatever.
Yeah,
they came out and there was the,
uh,
one of this,
they still gave it to me whether they had the scores correctly,
but it was marked red versus blue.
It's on the Internet.
Oh,
so they marked the wrong corner of the room.
Still judging from Mayweather.
Yeah.
Well there's a lot of fucking shitty people that are involved in every sport.
There's,
you're always gonna have that.
There's definitely a lot of shitty boxing judges,
but I just think that having a shitty boxing judge is almost less excusable than
having a shitty MMA judge.
Cause there's so many fucking boxing fans,
there's so many guys that have been doing it for so long.
And if you listen to like Harold Letterman on Hbo,
I very rarely disagree with that guy.
I listened to his scorecards.
It makes sense.
And I hear what he's saying.
You know,
I'm the same Steve Farr Hood.
Is that the guy's name that does it for showtime?
I think,
uh,
I think that's his name.
I think so.
I'm good that the showtime guys,
same thing mean they disagree on a round or two here or there,
but I,
their points are on there.
They,
they,
they know boxing.
They understand what the fuck is happening.
You know,
they,
they're appreciating everything that's going down while you're watching a fight.
You're telling me you can't find nine,
10 of those guys that only judged championship fights.
That's those the only guys ever like here's the list.
These are the best in the world.
Uh,
at judging boxing.
When you have a boxing match,
these are the only guys that should be able to judge.
It's just,
there's a reason there's three,
three judges.
It's cause if one of you makes a mistake,
the other two we'll fix it.
But have three judges have three completely different scorecards.
What are we do it here.
You know what I think we should do too,
because the fact that we have the internet today,
I think they should be,
there should be a panel of experts that you just have that are floating online.
Like say like,
you know,
pick out a bunch of guys.
Like a guy from bloody elbow,
a guy from SB nation,
a guy from a sure dog have like a bunch of guys who are real legit fans.
Journalists guys have been doing it for a long time and have that be like a
fourth judge.
Like say if you're in a situation where you,
you know,
you've got a close fight,
um,
have the three people calling it ringside w the,
and then the one group of people that agree on,
I would say maybe 80% of them agree that this guy won.
You know,
and that should count in the,
in the,
in the scoring system.
I think having three people is not enough people.
I think you should have a bunch of people that judge a fight
and then you get to a point where it's like,
okay,
you could question or you're going to,
uh,
what do you call it?
Like appeal the decision or whatever.
Nobody ever wins those.
Nobody ever wins.
But the reason they don't,
when is the same reason why the police never get charged with a murder?
When they kill people,
it's because they protect their own.
So the head of the Athletic Commission writes you a letter says yes,
she made valid points,
but we need to support our,
our people because they don't want to say that,
you know,
our guys screwed up,
you know?
And that's a,
so the fighter has to eat it.
You know,
dad is a real issue and that's,
that's messed up.
You know,
it should be some sort of,
you know,
if you make a mistake you have to pay for the consequences or own up to it.
But it's like when the judges are,
they athletic commission makes a mistake.
It's the fighter that has to,
that suffers from,
it has to deal with consequences.
I just think it's wrong.
There was a real issue with that,
with the Nevada state athletic commission.
They ousted the athletic commission chamber.
The,
the,
uh,
head of the athletic commission is gone
when,
uh,
you know,
one of my charts I got,
I got a swept what was questionably illegal sweep and I got slammed on my head
and the referee didn't see it and let me stand up,
walk in the wrong way.
And then I got teed off on and they called it a knockout.
And I appealed the athletic commission.
I had three different videos with footage of showing that it was an illegal
sweep and that the referee wasn't paying attention.
It was like,
no way,
I'm not winning this one.
And,
uh,
Kaiser wrote us a letter saying,
you know,
although you made very good points,
we need to support our athletic commission and nothing happened.
Yeah.
He's the dude that wasn't going to bring them up by name.
He's a bad guy either.
But Kaiser is a,
he's a politician,
you know,
and that's why he's,
that's why he got ousted.
And then my next fight,
uh,
I score a knockdown the jab and like the first round and then the scorecards
come out and two of the judges didn't count the knockdown.
It just didn't count that the eight,
the eight point must system why he won by one or I lost,
he won by one point.
It was like where's the,
I forget what the score was but there was,
there was no way he could have scored that many points.
They would come to the knockdown that's,
that was in Nevada.
Yeah.
There's a lot of shady shit going on when it comes to judging.
Just the idea that what drives me crazy is the idea that someone who is not a
practitioner doesn't understand what's happening.
It's never really been punched in the face.
Probably their whole life can judge a pro kickboxing bout like that.
That's bananas.
It doesn't make any sense.
Like how did that guy get that Gig?
Especially Jujitsu and MMA because if you don't understand what the fuck,
like if you're like,
say if a fight goes to the ground and the guy in the bottom is threatening with
a submissions and the,
the,
the referee or the judge rather doesn't score it for him because he doesn't
understand how close the guy was to get it
to the guy that was on the bottom has a knee bar but he's on the bottom or an
ankle lock or whatever it is.
But he's on the bottom,
but he's almost got it,
you know,
and the guys wincing in pain,
but he's on top.
But the other prison,
all they could see as the guys asked from the inside,
they don't know.
So that guy wins the round cause he helped her out and for two rounds,
well we had a fight for,
um,
for those,
judges to get screens for them to get monitors to watch the asked you about that
last time.
That's really important.
Yeah.
We had a fight for that.
That was big because I'll tell you,
man,
I don't see a lot of shit that's happening and I'm fucking,
it's close as anybody alive.
Right.
I'm right there.
I'm touching the floor next to the cage with my hands while the fights going on
and sometimes I can't see shit.
What's 30 feet across the cage,
right.
I think the cage is too big too.
We used to use a smaller one for the,
um,
for uh,
the,
the WEC and for the hard Ron fights.
We used to do fights at the hard rock and we'd be in a smaller cage.
I liked that one better.
I think forces guys,
I mean,
you could still move.
It's not,
it's not like you're fighting in a phone booth,
but the idea that you could literally run,
I mean you could sprint away from a guy in the octagon.
It's so big.
Yeah.
I mean they're greedy.
What don't they want more seats in the arena is shrink that pitch up.
Put some more fucking seats.
Why did they do the cash?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
Maybe it looks more grand or something like that.
I really don't understand it.
It's the smaller cage is plenty big.
It's still really big.
The boats were cases smaller.
Like here's this 30,
I think ours is 25.
We try and say bell two is better.
I think Bella towards better.
But do you think about this a Reebok sponsorship shit that's gone down.
This is a big deal right now in MMA that Reebok is the official sponsor for the
UFC.
Fighters can't have independent sponsors when they walk into the cage now and
financially it seems to be a huge disaster for the fighters.
I think that I'm glad I five her Bella tour and you can sponsor me for Bella
tour if you'd like.
And do you have a management Maryann management that they can contact your send
sponsorship?
Michael Colgan.
Oh,
there you go.
Yeah.
He told me to say hello to you.
I'll tell him I said what's up?
Yeah.
I think,
um,
it's,
whenever you see these guys complaining and talking about the difference in the
amount of pay that they're getting,
like that's not,
that's not good.
It's not just not good,
like all that stuff had to be worked out,
I think should have been worked out in advance.
It's great to have a big sponsor like Reebok involved,
but not if the fighters have to suffer.
Yeah,
I think it's just a,
when it came out,
it was,
you know,
I think everyone kind of saw this coming.
You know,
Tim Kennedy did a tweet today.
He said he was getting 2,500 or something for his,
and that's the only sponsor that you're allowed to allowed to have.
You know,
it's a,
well,
Brendan Shop said he would be getting 10 grand,
but every single fight that he had before this,
he was getting more than he was getting six figures is what he said.
So I mean,
at least a hundred thousand I don't know how much,
six figures,
you know,
it could mean as much as 900,000 for every fight.
So six figures for every fight and then now he's making 10 grand.
That's a,
that's a big hit.
Yeah,
it's huge.
It's huge.
And it's based off the raking,
you know?
So if you're,
I guess if you're Chris Weidman is going to get more money than that,
well even the champs get 40 grand,
the champs,
the best guys in the world get 40 grand.
That's a,
that doesn't seem like enough to me.
No,
it just doesn't seem right.
Um,
look,
I'm not a businessman.
I'd be the shittiest businessman in the world if I,
if I own the UFC,
the UFC would probably be filing for bankruptcy right now.
I would never have gotten it to where it is.
I would never done any of the smart moves that these guys had done.
I'm an idiot when it comes to business,
but,
uh,
I,
I just don't,
I don't like when I see fighters suffering financially,
I don't like it at all.
It's just a really weird thing.
You know,
it's great for bill tour and the guys ability to work cause you know,
all of those sponsors that can no longer sponsor in the UFC.
It got to go somewhere in June or July.
What do you think about a fighters' union?
I mean,
I was going back and forth with John Fitch about that today.
And John Fitch actually,
he posted something like,
let me pull it up because I'm
spiders intelligent guy,
John Fitches,
I saw some of the videos he posted like a,
he's very smart of him talking politics.
I was like,
God,
I wish I could speak that well.
Yeah,
he's a,
he's a very smart dude.
He wrote,
um,
I,
I posted something about MMA being illegal in New York is New York.
Just a,
there was a,
uh,
an article that was posted about New York being the corruption capital of
America,
more corruption
in New York than anywhere else.
And uh,
when I posted it,
John Fitch said that,
he said,
no,
the reason MMA is illegal in New York is because of Zuph is treatment of
employees,
both fighters and
tell workers,
which is not really true.
Even if you disagree with the way UFC treats,
uh,
fighters or hotel workers.
And what,
when they say hotel workers,
they don't make my intelligent comment.
I think he's just saying that because you know,
he's,
he's upset,
you know,
I don't think he's a,
he's not happy with a,
the way a lot of things went down,
but it's old school boxing,
uh,
politics.
It is 100%.
That's the boxing commission in New York.
They have no other athletic commission as far as kickboxing.
They don't sanction kickboxing there either.
They have a,
their own sanctioning body that's not a state run thing in New York.
Yes.
So there's no,
you know,
the benefit of having athletic commission went as a fighter is that you're
guaranteed to get paid.
You're guaranteed to have,
uh,
health insurance for the fight if you get hurt or whatnot.
And when,
um,
it's not through the state,
you know,
the Iks the what,
any letters you want to put together,
you don't have that same confidence.
And I'm in New York,
it's only boxing.
Then you have the wk when you fight in New York,
and,
and a lot of states that are too small to have that led a commission.
But it's,
yeah,
it's,
it's uh,
boxing has been huge in New York for eternity and that's what they want.
You know,
it's also the culinary union,
the culinary,
when he was talking about hotel workers,
what he's talking about is the culinary,
the UFC.
This is the,
the,
the long and short of it.
The UFC is owned by [inaudible] also owns the people that own Zoomba also own
station casinos.
They own 20 plus casinos in Vegas and they're non union.
The employees voted for them to be non union.
The union wants it to turn union because it was union.
They'd make some,
uh,
somewhere around $15 million a year just from the station casinos.
So they've had this campaign for years to try to get the UFC to acquiesce and
become a union,
a casino station,
Casino Union casino.
So they have this smear campaign against the UFC.
And so that's what he's saying when he's saying hotel workers.
That's what he means.
He doesn't mean like the UFC shows up
now hotel workers,
how does he know all this stuff?
I know Tim Kennedy,
my Twitter got hacked yesterday.
He gets say that without any irony whatsoever.
That's a wait,
I love Jane Kennedy.
He's a bad motherfucker.
But uh,
so John Fitch posted about this thing,
uh,
m m a f a mixed martial arts fighters association.
Uh,
m.
M a f a is on Twitter.
Uh,
there's,
I guess a guy named Rob May,
uh,
may Macy,
He must be in charge of it.
And I don't think it's a bad idea to have some sort of an organization that
looks out for,
uh,
for fighters.
And I also think that it's,
it's super important to have something like tour like that is owned by Viacom
that starts to come up in the public's consciousness and become bigger and
bigger and have more competition.
I think competition is,
it's the best.
The only way you get in fight like Manny pack yellow versus Floyd Mayweather is
he have two bad motherfuckers who are on rival promotions.
They get together and showtime and HBO both got together and said,
listen,
let's make some money that's put this fucking thing together.
These are the two biggest fighters in the world.
You're going to make the 4.5 million paper view bys.
I mean that's fucking insane.
At 100 bucks and nothing like that exists in MMA.
And if Bella tour had a champion,
you know,
if you become champion at Bella Chore at 185 pounds and it,
it builds up where you're knocking dudes dead and then you know,
whoever is in the UFC at the same time,
you know why men are Vituro shocker,
right?
Whoever the fuck it is,
if it builds up in the public's consciousness like this fight has to happen.
It has to take place.
Yes.
Well sort of,
sort of tried to,
didn't really work.
I mean the,
the,
they tried to make an agreement with pride and you know,
the UFC sent chuck Ladell over there and then,
you know,
pride was supposed to send some fighters over here but it never happened.
They brought over Vandelay and Vandelay and chuck,
you know,
had that stare down the octagon.
But it wasn't until years later when pride was purchased by the UFC that the,
the fighters actually came,
right.
It was mostly some Japanese fuckery.
Those guys are heard.
There's a lot of fuckery.
But yeah.
Was lost.
Slickness those guys are slick.
I mean,
not in a good way,
but you know,
they made a lot of money doing that.
You know what the whole pride UFC thing happened,
you know,
do you know the story behind it?
The UFC purchase pride for $65 million.
When they got it,
they realized that all the contracts were invalid.
There were all illegal.
They were all they had was a library.
They essentially had a library of Dvds and tapes,
which good luck making 65 million off of that.
And so then they tried to sell it,
you know,
or try to,
um,
uh,
to sue them and the,
that didn't really work.
I mean,
good luck trying to sue someone in Japan,
you know,
what are you gonna keep flying over Japan every couple of weeks for court dates
and,
and on top of that extension.
Yeah.
While they were,
um,
while they bought pride,
they were going to keep the pride office open and have like,
you know,
they're going to start running pride events in Japan and they realize how much,
how hard it is to do.
Like it's not easy.
It's not like you're just going to like,
you would do a event New Mexico,
you know,
it's,
it's a totally different country.
I mean they have completely different laws,
completely different customs and the people that were working for them,
they were all,
while they had an office running,
the people who are working for them started putting together dream.
So then they,
they,
they put together their own MMA organization and started putting on their own
fights.
It's fucking chaos.
So I that contract or that it's the context was legally shots.
Why fade or never came to the UFC initially?
The reason why fade or wasn't a part of the pride deals,
the contracts would talk shit.
There was nothing there.
And that was their big fader is probably a big reason behind buying pride.
Oh,
how could you not want fate or to come over?
I mean they tried hard to get fade or a lot of people don't realize that,
uh,
how hard they try.
But it was a good view of she fucking cared about putting on the right foods due
to her food or come over.
They would m one global who are the people that promote fade or they wanted to
have co-promotion rights to the UFC.
But the problem is that's not like they don't have,
there's no promotion.
They're like,
it's just a management team of fader.
Like you see,
they wouldn't really be promoting anything.
They would just be glomming on and making.
So the UFC offered them a big percentage of the pay per view buys a large chunk
of money you would get when fade or fights.
They want it to be co promotion,
they want it to be the UFC and [inaudible] glow.
Who the fuck is m one global?
Nobody knows what that is.
Like three shows on it.
Yeah.
You're not talking about like showtime and Hbo or like Bob Arum and t,
you know,
and golden boy productions to establish companies.
You're talking about one company that fucking no one knows.
And one company that's the NFL of MMA.
So it didn't make any sense.
They offered him a fuck load of money.
And then Dana,
we said,
listen,
you guys got to realize that this guy can lose and if he loses this ain't worth
shit.
Like as soon as he loses this is not worth anything.
And then he goes to strike for us and then V for doom triangles,
them wraps him up,
taps him out and like that's it.
Everything just got weird.
And then after that big foot pizza,
fuck out of him.
And then after that Henderson Kaos him that said there goes your,
there goes your big money,
it all went away and there goes the dreams man.
The fucking fights a good a band with that guy in the UFC would have been
amazing.
But that's how it goes.
Japanese fuckery,
Japanese fuckery.
The apparently the way they do businesses,
lot of,
they'll say,
oh we will get together and have a meeting and we are interested in selling
pride.
And then,
you know,
then they get together and everyone,
he gets really excited and there's all this publicity and they go,
Huh,
we change our mind but we have a big event next week and then they put on this
big event.
Now they have all this publicity because they,
the UFC is going to by pride and then they have to put on this fucking gigantic
show and it's very clever.
They just have a different way of approach ever figure out what the microphone
was about.
Like why did they have the headset?
What did the referee have?
A headset so he could talk,
made some accusations,
but oh,
he was saying that the there was fake.
Yeah,
he was just fucking with fighters.
Fucking makes some good points.
Why would he have a headset?
Well there is a problem with some of the fights in pride that we're clearly
fixed.
Right?
There's no doubt about it.
There can be no doubt you watch Mark Coleman versus Takata if you don't think
that that fight was fixed,
you're an asshole.
And the k one two oh yeah,
yeah.
So I'll tell him boo cow.
Like how them was killed.
Masato trying to get to win over blue cow.
Oh yeah.
Three routes and they give an extra round and then he kills him in the fourth
round of this extra round and he could see massage.
Like what the fuck really?
And like boot cal was just kicking the fuck out of him and I guess Masato had to
retire for like eight months or something.
The internal bleeding,
it was bad,
was bad.
They always,
uh,
that's a finance are kind of known for uh,
trying to get the,
the Japanese when,
yeah,
there's always going to be that.
There's always going to be a little bit of that.
But yeah,
it's fun,
man.
The,
the,
the glory,
early days of MMA and kickboxing.
And look,
when you,
you look at that,
like say,
you know,
they did,
they definitely did some fuckery,
but they put k one on the map and therefore kickboxing on the map on a grand
scale.
When you look at those k one grom priests and they're in the Tokyo Dome in front
of like,
God knows how many thousands of people.
That was amazing.
That was a as well.
I fell in love with kickbox.
That was my,
my dream was always watching those,
those world Grand Prix and then the cold wet glory was like,
Oh,
you want to find it when night tournament.
Yeah.
Waiting my whole life for this.
Well I just hope that glory and there's a big event that's going on this Friday
night.
They're doing regular events on spike.
Um,
I just hope that it can achieve the same sort of level in America that the UFC
has or that pride and k one had in Japan.
And I just think if you look at the quality of the,
the fights that they're putting on,
it's right up there.
It's an amazing,
I think they're the best quality as far as the,
the,
the level of the strikers,
the best quality we've ever had.
Guys like you and Nikki holds skin and,
and mark the box.
It's like so many guys that are like at a super high level in,
in,
in glory right now.
Yeah.
It's really exciting.
They're putting them in the production value on their shows is really good.
It's,
yeah.
I just hope people keep tuning in or start tuning in.
All their ratings have been a little questionable lately on some really big
carts.
And uh,
yeah,
man,
they just need more push.
They need to keep,
don't they need to keep doing it.
And eventually I think it's gonna catch on guys like Raymond Daniels,
Joseph out the Leni.
There's like,
there's so many high level guys that are fighting exciting fights.
There were wild,
exciting fights to watch.
I just can't see it not working.
I just think it just has to a,
it just has to keep pushing,
you know?
That's all it is.
I mean it's,
it's,
it seems to me like the product is there.
It's just a matter of letting people about it.
Yeah.
And then this,
uh,
you know,
having it on spike is good too.
Having that Friday nights fight thing every Friday night,
they f fights on spike,
whether it's a bell,
a tour van or a boxing event or Gloria event.
Yeah.
They can keep that up.
That could be,
that could be really big.
That's huge.
This PVC boxing cards had been pretty awesome on there too.
Yeah,
yeah.
He's been really good on that.
It's been,
uh,
you know,
he said boxing is dead,
but it seems like there's a,
there's a lot of buzz behind boxing,
wrestling.
Can you say it's dead when they have,
you know,
4.5 million paper view,
but I'm looking forward to Canelo Alvarez versus James Kirkland this weekend.
That's going to be fucking crazy.
Yeah.
But I heard Kirklin I realized that I watched the uh,
you know,
the countdown show that they were doing about it,
whatever they call it,
24,
seven and a Kirkland didn't train with Ann Wolfe for this fight.
No.
Which is like,
if you ever thought like a guy definitely should be training with a woman
trainer,
like in any,
in any other sports that ever happened in a combat sport,
you'd be like,
what?
But if you look at like the shit that Ann Wolfe would make him do,
she would get in a truck and she had a heavy bag attached to an arm on the front
of the truck and then the truck would move forward at like a certain amount of
miles per hour.
And he was forced to back up and punch the bag as he's backing up doing
roadwork.
Never seen anybody do that before.
They didn't know.
But they showed it in the,
you know,
in the,
uh,
the,
the training montages and stuff.
And I was like,
dad is a fucking great idea because you have to keep up.
You've got it.
Yeah.
Trucks coming your way.
You know you've got a backup and you know,
you can't take any breaks.
Like,
you know,
for whatever reason,
how many mount rounds she's making them do or how many minutes she's making them
do as he's backing up,
he's got to hit that fucking bag.
And when he was with her,
his conditioning was on point.
Man.
I mean,
he,
she put him through hell,
but some dudes don't want to go through hell.
They will.
They go through hell a few times.
Like Bj Penn with Marvin [inaudible],
he went through hell a few times and he was like,
fuck this man.
I'm not going to,
I had a strength coach couple years back that was awful.
We stopped doing it.
But,
uh,
Yo,
the,
I was really successful and I was with him.
Fucking hell for sure.
That's what it is though,
right?
It's like this,
this nick curse on guy who trained a Hofeld dos Anjos is one of the reasons why
I can't wait to talk to him.
It's because when you put those guys through hell like that,
the results are undeniable,
but it's a matter of like,
how much should,
how much should that replace skill training.
Right.
You know,
like,
like here's a perfect example.
Um,
say if a guy like rich Franklin had gone through a guy like Marinovich when he
fought Anderson Silva,
he still would not have been technically able to deal with Anderson striking.
Right?
Well,
it wasn't rich like,
wasn't the where he's training?
Did we talk about that?
Like he was,
uh,
yeah,
he had some pretty intense,
intense,
hardest trading fighters at the time or whatever.
Yeah,
he will at the time.
I mean,
I don't know.
And he just stands up.
It was a big boy.
Huge.
Yeah,
it was,
but yeah,
it just didn't have,
it was the clinch didn't have the answer for the clench.
That's a technical thing.
You could have trained all day,
every day and it's not going to change.
You're lacking in that area.
You know.
He also didn't have the answer standing up.
I mean,
even outside of the clinch,
you know,
when you see Anderson drop his hands and Shuck and jive in front of him,
my Franklin throws punches and kicks it.
Air Anderson's just ducking under the kicks and looking at it.
I'm like,
that's a terrifying place to be when you're standing there with a guy who he
knows you can't hit him.
Did you ever see his fight Anderson's fight with Jorge Rivera in cage warriors?
Cage rage,
whatever the fuck it was and no,
the only one I remember was his fight with the Tony frequently the back.
Yeah,
the cage rage.
I was an early,
yeah,
he fought.
He fought,
um,
Jorge Rivera and he let Jorge Rivera Punch him in the face over.
And horror is known as a knockout guy and he punches him three,
four times clean in the face.
And Anderson just staring at him smiling like literally let him tee off on its
face.
So scared to do that.
It doesn't jam.
You can get stupid and stuff like that.
But what if that goes bad?
What would it feel that hit me and I like,
well,
every Anderson and Weidman,
I mean the clowning around ultimately will happen.
Huh?
That was the worst ever moment.
An innocence career.
And the biggest example why she'd never clown around in a fight.
That was,
uh,
that was one of those things that you,
when it's happening,
you don't believe it's happening.
Like what?
What are we seeing?
Like you almost have to shake your hand.
Like what is this?
Because like that's what everybody wants to see.
What's that like?
Lay down.
I'm like,
no mother fucker.
He laid down and put his hand on his head like he's taking a nap.
It's so funny,
Dude.
I was slamming my hands against the table.
Just posted a clip the other day and you can hear yourself laughing.
You can actually see me across this.
I can't tell if I'm excited or not,
but to stand up and I'm screaming something.
That was a crazy fight,
man.
It was weird
being being there for that and then watching Anderson after it was over,
realizing how much pressure was on him when he just laid down and started
weeping like,
whoa.
Yeah.
Is it,
there's big,
the memes about this are awesome.
All the
pose.
Don't stand up homie.
Oh my God,
he's so funny.
He was so crazy.
The goat and Anderson Silva as far as like a dude that people love to see fight
is,
you don't get much better than nick.
No.
People love that.
Kelly is fucking,
I couldn't believe he did it and that's have to talk in all kinds of mad shit
that we all would.
None of us knew that was going to happen today.
He probably didn't even know.
He wasn't,
you know,
it was real respectful talking about him,
even throughout the whole camp you and be like,
oh you going to fucking mom bird saying anything to him?
And he's like,
oh,
I don't know.
I'm just going to survive.
She can survive.
And I'm like,
I'm gonna kick his fucking ass.
What you mean by they were in the back and he's like said something like,
Oh yeah,
I might,
I might fuck with him or something.
And I was like,
oh,
okay.
You know about.
They're like,
what the fuck is all this shit?
It was awesome though.
It was great.
And you could,
we could see how much it was messing with Anderson right away when he started
doing it.
Like he fucks with everybody's perspective.
Yeah,
it's really effective.
But Nick Fox with everybody said he fucked with Robbie Lawler's head.
You could really see it in that robbery hour flight.
Like Robbie Lawler was used to just going Berserk on guys and all of a sudden
nick was like,
what bitch?
What bitch?
What's up bitch?
And it's like stand in front of his face.
You could see Ravi.
Yeah,
it was affected.
And for sure when nick onto the cage,
I'll never forget that fight because he got in the cage and he looked over at
Robbie,
starts going stocked in,
motherfucker stocked him mother fucker.
And Andy Robby was like looking around like,
what,
what's happening here?
Where is Stockton?
Where's this?
Where's this going to lead?
Like this is bizarre.
Like it's just a totally different thing.
Would Have Robbie would have been like de Moines,
Iowa Bitch.
Yeah.
It was um,
a very rare moment in time.
This is a,
a big card coming up this weekend,
right?
The glory card.
Me Goodwin.
Who's on this?
I got a here queued up here.
It's a Simon and um,
art Tim for the,
for the belt.
If you don't have m spike,
you could watch it online.
If you go to glory world series.com,
you could stream it for only 10 bucks and a arts and 11.
And Simon Marcus,
Artem,
Levin,
uh,
one of the best kickboxers on earth for sure.
So is Marcus Simon Marcus one of the best on earth too.
And uh,
they're gonna fight.
You have two really interesting styles,
you know,
having fought both of them are,
Tim is very much like a Floyd Mayweather kind of a,
he's very elusive.
He'll score is points and then hold and kind of eats up the clock really well.
Um,
and then Simon is one of those just like bull forward,
constantly coming forward,
constantly trying to uh,
you know,
having,
having fought both of them.
Simon,
when you're,
when you're standing across the room from Simon,
you see somebody that you have to knock out.
Like he's going to keep coming at me no matter what.
There's no weakness in his mindset.
He's going to keep coming until I knock him out with the art team.
It's like supreme confidence.
It's to go really.
It's very interesting standing across from both of those guys and both guys have
had a long career.
I mean,
you look at a look at the records there,
54 and one for 1142 two and one from Marcus and [inaudible] and Marcus up until
your fight was undefeated,
you knocked him out and then he lost in China again after that as well.
Right.
Aco and China.
I think that was one of those things for like we were talking about before where
he didn't take the time off after I knocked him out.
And that was a bad knock out your face plant.
You're out for a long period of time,
you know?
And then he got,
he got rocked again and China right after that.
Who fought him in China.
Oh,
I don't know the guy's name.
And he wasn't even a big,
big name is Chinese guy.
The Chinese guy.
I them in China.
Crazy.
Go figure.
It's like a Russian guy I find in Russia.
But uh,
yeah.
And then he came back and won the,
a contender tournament against Jason Wellness and uh,
Wayne Barrett.
Now Raymond Daniels was fighting in the car too.
He's an La guy.
Do you train with him at all?
Um,
I was on the,
I did that world combat league like six years ago.
We were on the same team.
I have met him and got to know him a little bit then we haven't tried together.
That was a chuck Norris thing.
Yeah.
Now the truck nars thing took place in like a bowl,
right?
Yeah.
What'd you think about that?
I hated it.
I hated it was terrible.
I thought it was,
it was,
it was really set up specifically for point karate guys to do well.
It was just like everything against like the kickboxer really were wearing those
pants.
Right.
But underneath the pants we have like the sport Combate super thick Shin pads
underneath the pants.
Oh really?
So like you know,
your leg kick is,
and it's a one round,
it's three minutes and then you have,
you know,
30 minutes or whatever until you come back out and you fight your s your second
round or whatever.
So it's really hard to be effective with,
with round kicks in general with the Shin Pad on and it's only one round.
You know,
the Shin Pad is a weird thing,
but it's not weird when you think about the fact that the guys wear gloves and
that you'll also,
I w I always wonder,
especially in MMA,
like why do they have gloves on?
Like if you really,
we've been talking about this a lot lately,
that if you wanted to lessen the effectiveness of,
uh,
of,
like punching techniques,
one of the best ways to just remove the gloves,
right?
Like if you remove the gloves,
you make guys fight bare handed,
you get to see what,
what's really effective and not effective when it comes to striking.
Yeah.
You still can kick guys in the head.
You still,
but you couldn't eat.
You guys,
Nigga only kicked him in the head with the Shin Pad on,
like,
imagine if you,
you mean in life without parole comment?
Imagine punching somebody in the leg with a glove on.
Yeah.
It's like it takes away all of the effectiveness to,
it's different when you meet somebody in the chin,
you know,
but you'd have to hit somebody really fucking hard if with a punch to the leg to
hurt them,
which is essentially what that Shin Pad would be doing for it.
And I just,
I hated the rules.
I hated that circle threw me off big time being in a circle with no ropes and
then you,
you get into an exchange and you just step back and you would be on this,
this slant,
you know,
why did,
why does everybody have to wear those pants?
Uh,
it was something about the sponsors that,
you know,
I got uh,
I got in a lot of trouble because I had like sponsors like Henna tattooed on my
back,
cause they wouldn't let us put anything on the pants.
And after the first fight,
the director or whatever,
it comes to the back and he's screaming and yelling and Chuck Norris is really
mad at you.
And Oh my God,
Chuck Norris is mad at me.
Is He mad?
It was like really pissed off that I was,
you know,
taking the advantage of something.
Did they not stated in the rules?
I think it was in the rules that you couldn't do it or you said you couldn't,
you couldn't have anything on,
you couldn't alter the uniform,
you couldn't put patches or anything that uniform.
And I'm like,
well he had a tattoo on my back.
It's like,
pardon permanent marker.
That was
the guy's like dumping water on me the bag and like scrubbing it.
And it wasn't even like he was trying to get it off.
He was just trying to screw it up.
So my sponsor would be,
you know,
did it work and I got paid.
I didn't.
Did it mess it up at all though?
I mean Hannah Tycho yeah,
it messed it up.
It will cause it was like you get like Keana with me.
We went to like Venice beach to get it done.
Like before I left and then like come in the hotel room and it's all like
smeared and bad and I'm like,
Hey,
can you cover this?
Like the other guy,
that team with a sharpie dental little you might be even better than Hannah,
right?
Yeah.
Things like that might last even longer.
So they were scrubbing it.
It was whatever.
That was an issue with the UFC wants with Ricoh Rodriguez.
He had some uh,
golden palace.
Yeah.
That was back when they had online gambling was like really popular.
Did Not Bernard Hopkins you that wants to,
I feel like God guys were doing that in boxing.
Boxing and having a lot.
Yeah.
But they stopped.
So how are they put a stop to it?
Of why though?
Why?
I don't know.
I mean the UFC a unit maroon,
the man or something Kinda does fuck with what you're looking at.
I mean,
it doesn't matter to me if a guy has sponsors all over shorts,
but if he's got like a big sponsored tattooed on his back,
it just seems like tips kind of cheesy.
Yeah.
Like low,
low rent.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't want to cut into a guy's ability to make money,
but that does seem a little low rent.
Yeah.
Golden pals.com
back in the day.
He's a fucking freak,
Huh?
49 years old.
Still fighting at a world class level.
The alien fights against Coleville [inaudible] who's a murderous puncher.
Russians are a different kind of white people,
Huh?
Yeah.
Yeah,
they really are.
But this glove getting guy who's a mother fucker only God.
I love that dude.
I love him and he'll knock you out with shots that it doesn't mean if any,
and I were talking to him about about him the other day,
like it doesn't look like he's trying to hit you hard,
but like when he throws it all natural and loose,
it's like he knows it's going to knock you out.
He's knocking people out with like body shots that don't look hard.
Look like they missed.
People are dropping.
Awesome.
Yeah,
his left hook to the body.
Fucking devastating.
One of the best in the business who he fought,
but he threw her right hand in it like it looked like it slid off.
Didn't even know it was like penetration at all.
And the guys don't knock out these two fights ago.
You get to go with it.
Yeah.
He's a motherfucker do hazing.
He's,
he's awesome.
He's really awesome.
I love the fact that there's so many guys like that.
Now.
I Cam Kovalev um,
uh,
providing a cough.
I love watching like a savage,
like Oh,
debt fight that he had with Lucas Matisa Jesus Christ.
That was crazy.
Did you see the a urine sample after the fight?
No Dude.
Pull that up cause you got to see this.
He posted an Instagram photo of his urine sample and it looks like he poured
Coca Cola into the cup.
Like he was pissing just so dark from blood and you know,
internal bleeding and leading and you know,
a lot of apparently not just internal bleeding,
but when you have an unbelievably grueling physical event like ultra marathons,
like we'll get it up there.
That's his Pittsboro what?
Yes.
But pull up the actual Instagram so you could see it and we could read it.
Yeah.
That's his urine sample man.
That his urine sample.
That's the urine sample that he gave the Athletic Commission,
the Post doping post-fight cause I've been before,
but it was nothing that dark like that.
It was like fucking orange.
Well I have a friend who did an ultra marathon.
Um,
my friend Cameron Hanes and uh,
he said the same thing that when you,
when you do an ultra marathon,
when you pay,
it looks like Coca Cola.
Really?
Yeah.
It's like your kidneys are failing.
Know Fuck yeah,
here it is.
Sorry,
I told my friends I lost tonight and I felt like I could have won this fight.
I almost had him,
but the fight happened the way it happened and here it is.
He's saying,
uh,
one more fight in my career when I did my doping test,
I had black urine.
That one,
the first one was against Tim Bradley.
It's black urine ball,
lack urine.
Fuck Dude.
I think it's an endurance thing too.
It's just a kidney failure thing cause the guys who have luck and crazy,
I can't believe that's real.
Yeah,
it's totally real.
Those guys who have Rhabdo rhabdomyolysis from a crossfit and she'll like,
that's one of the signs of it.
You get black urine,
but ultra marathoners,
they all talk about it.
Black urine.
What's the mission of the ultra marathon and a regular 100 miles in a day.
24 hours is 24 hour race.
You run a hundred miles
and you just broken when it's over.
I mean,
why?
Why did they do that?
Prove they can do it.
Yeah.
My friend Cameron who does it as a fucking savage,
she's just a psychopath because he like really skinny guy and he's 170 pounds.
Pretty yoked actually.
Really?
Yeah.
He's a bow hunter.
He's a professional bow hunter and he got started getting into endurance
training because bow hunting you would think is not a physical event,
but with a physical event is,
is getting to the animals up the mountains and packing out all the meat.
So like you're going,
like I had this guy Remy warrant on the podcast recently and he was talking
about how they had to pack out this,
a little moose or an elk.
They shot Moose and elk,
one of those big fucking animal.
Okay.
And he's packing out a hundred plus pounds at a time,
walking several miles back with 100 plus pounds,
add elevation,
going up mountains down mountains,
and then going back.
So he,
over the course of,
you know,
x amount of days when they packed all the meat out,
it took them,
it was 30 miles of walking with a hundred pounds on your back up mountains.
And he's like,
after it was over,
he goes like,
I was just done.
He goes,
I got sick,
I was exhausted,
my body was just broken.
That's you don't think about,
and these guys that do it,
like Cameron every year it goes elk hunting in the mountains,
shoots a big elk every year,
has to carry it out.
And so he does all these crazy workouts.
And one of them he does,
he takes 'em one of these,
uh,
like a meat backpack.
They call it 10 zinc backpack and he puts on,
puts 135 pound rock and the backpack and he'll fucking hike up hills with this
fucking Brock on his back.
Miles and miles,
man,
I realize how spoiled,
at least as good as my buddies,
uncle's property,
they hike a little bit there when we'd shoot the thing and drag it to where he'd
get to it and call him and he bring a fucking four wheeler and tried to shut up.
It was hanging in the barn.
Yeah.
That's uh,
that's the easy way.
Yeah.
And it spoiled.
Well,
that's a,
that's the way most people do it.
Tree stands,
you know,
but when you go for elk and the mountains though,
the big elk,
oftentimes they're,
they're hard to get to there.
They're smart.
They're not going to hang around to your house.
They're going to go up in the mountains and they're trying to get some elk,
pussy and you got to,
you got to sneak him,
sneak up to them,
and then you've got to call him in and,
and then once you shoot him,
then you got to cut them up and drag him out of there.
That's fucking crazy.
Yeah.
So that's why he does ultra marathons.
He's sort of got into running and fitness because of that.
And then escalated.
Just asked who skinny.
It's usually those marathon or like super,
you know all the triathlete guys.
I know they're ready to pull up his Instagram cause he's got a bunch of pictures
of him.
Sexy bitch likes to show his muscles.
Yeah,
there's all these,
he just,
he's an animal.
47 years old.
Works fulltime job trains every day.
Every fucking day.
Runs every morning lifts every night.
He's a fucking animal.
That's him.
I would never sit and think that was even a marathon guy.
Little ultra marathons.
We just ran the Boston marathon in under three hours.
He did two,
two hours and 50 minutes.
But yeah,
he's,
he's an animal,
Huh?
Just killing shit.
Eating wild meat.
That's a big part of it too.
Like if you see like pull up a little bit from up there above the,
yeah,
that's him in the marathon.
But there's a picture of his legs would go.
Keeps crawling up,
up,
up.
Not Down Up.
Okay.
Go down a little.
There's a right there like you see like a fucking veins is,
dude's gotten his legs.
He's using some sort of massaging tool,
but that's him.
It's just a driven dude,
man.
I would've never thought that was a marathon guy.
I don't know.
We'll see.
You'd be amazed at the kind of fitness that you need to have.
Just a hike,
eight hours a day in the mountains.
That sounds,
we're talking about a lot of stuff that just gets really depressing.
Yeah,
it's a lot of work.
I don't work out there.
There's a lot of things that people would like to do,
but it's just too much work.
Then I would,
I'd probably say that what you do for a living is at the very top of that list
and you're looking at this guy carrying,
you know,
caring elk steaks,
running up hills and like,
fuck that.
Meanwhile would be looking at you fighting three times in a night going,
No,
fuck that.
Everybody wants to eat.
A few are willing to hunt.
That's what,
yeah,
look at that.
He's got a pack full with meat and giant ass fucking antlers carrying that pitch
out there.
I used to hunt all the time when I was growing up in Ohio.
Yeah.
Deer hunting all the time.
It's been a long time.
Best Meat for you man.
No better meat in the world.
And wild game was broke.
My brother and I were living in this
living together and we were,
you know,
every dollar was spent on like cigarettes and beer were like 17,
18,
19 I think.
And uh,
I guess I was younger than that.
17,
18.
And uh,
we would go a hunting every year and it'd be like three or four of us.
We'd all get a deer and we would chop up like every little piece and we haven't
been having like dear kebabs like for a whole year we were living off the deer
that was in the fridge.
That's good.
Tired.
It's great for you though,
man.
So good for you.
Do you ever get ahold of some now where you're training?
I'll get you some moose.
Moose for you.
Yeah.
Fuck Yeah Dude.
Oh yeah.
Moose.
It's tough.
It's tough for the IC or posts.
You're quite the chef on the with that.
I love it.
Like last night man,
I was coming home last night from the comedy store.
I was driving home,
I was like 1230 I was kind of tired of like I could just fucking slip right into
in and out right now and go,
nope.
I said just go home.
We got,
cause I knew I had some defrosted Moose and the and the frigerator so I went
home,
Cook some steaks and some keylock in and out.
Look at that.
Oh so good to that stuff.
Gives you energy to,
when I eat that it's something about Mousse.
I think something about those big athletic,
very lean animals.
I feel energized when I eat the meat.
That doesn't seem to make sense.
Could see the,
I don't know if they really have a,
an accurate account of all of the properties of various different kinds of meat.
You know,
I would like to see like if there,
if there's a way to do some sort of double blind placebo controlled effect test
on the difference between eating elk versus chicken or the difference between
eating,
you know w alligator versus beef.
I really would like to know.
I really,
I wonder what was the fuck is happening because I tried to look at it really
objectively.
Like I try not to like,
and maybe I'm,
this is a placebo effect.
Maybe I'm fucking with myself.
I don't think it is though.
When I eat moose like more than any other animal I've ever eaten.
There's something about when I eat it,
I feel like,
ah,
I just feel how fucking charged up man.
I don't know what it is.
I've heard of my,
I have a buddy of mine who,
uh,
was lifting.
He's a,
he's a,
he's a big fitness fanatic too.
And his wife shot an elk and a,
he was eating nothing but elk for months.
He's like,
dude,
I'm making all these fucking gains.
And I got to think it's connected to this elk.
He's like,
I've nothing but elk,
you know,
it doesn't have a lot of money.
And he's like,
we've been eating nothing but elk for like the past two months.
And he goes,
and I've gained like five pounds of muscle.
And maybe there's,
there's something to that horse beef thing that Overeem was talking about.
I mean,
obviously he's on whatever,
but like the fucking horse beef thing,
maybe it is.
Well eat a horse is kind of the same thing you're talking about shy,
super athletic.
I mean an animal that jumps over trees with you on its back,
you know that's a motherfucker you ever had horse?
No.
As a place called Joe beef in Montreal.
If you've never been to Montreal,
if you ever go up there to train at Tristar or something like that,
the best fucking restaurant on earth.
Yeah.
It's in Montreal.
I took my pal Tony Hinchcliffe there,
uh,
last week and uh,
that guy serves horse all the time and I've had it there twice.
It's good.
Yeah,
it's real good.
It's weird.
Is that Gamey or no?
No,
no,
not at all.
It's weird that you're eating a horse,
but I mean is,
is it,
I mean it's weird to eat a pig,
you know,
go watch babe and then have a,
have some bacon,
pigs like Waller and shit.
Like they live in like three feet of shit.
Eat all asleep and shit.
So that's,
that's not good.
That's gross.
It's nasty.
You have a wild pig?
No.
Looks different.
Yeah.
It's dark.
It's weird.
I think the flesh is dark.
I cooked a wild ham the other day.
[inaudible] see if it's on my Instagram,
I pulled up.
Uh,
yeah,
it's on my Instagram.
There's a wild ham from about three or four weeks ago
that it's Kinda like,
it's different than like boars are.
It's the same.
Well,
boar is just mail,
you know,
like if you shoot a male,
a male bear is also called a bore and a sal pig and a sal bear,
they're called,
uh,
the females called the south.
So when you got wild boar in a restaurant,
they're kind of bullshitting you.
It's not really wild.
It might be wild sal.
It's wild pig is what they should say.
But it sounds cool to say we're going wild boar hunting.
Yeah.
You're going to wild pig hunting.
I thought that,
but they're all pigs have like the fucking,
yeah,
there it is.
So that's what it looks like.
See up there.
That's what,
that's,
that's wild pig.
That's a female as a female that a shot at this place called the [inaudible]
ranch.
It's about an hour,
hour and a half north of here.
It's fucking delicious,
dude.
It's so good.
And it's very little fat on it.
Didn't compare it to domestic pig.
Much,
much less fat.
You got like a giant freezer home,
just full of shit to have them shut.
Yeah.
Two huge freezers.
Big commercial freezers.
Yeah.
Well I kinda decided like when I started getting into hunting,
I went,
the first time I went hunting,
I was like,
I'm either going to become a vegetarian or I'm going to become a hunter.
Like,
let's see,
like how I feel like after I shoot this and shoot it,
yeah.
I might feel like an asshole.
Maybe I'll just stick.
The only fish never really felt bad about fish.
They didn't even take care of their babies.
They ship them out and run away.
You know,
they,
they drop out the eggs.
Fuck fish.
A male comes off Jesus on the eggs and they bolt.
It's like the,
the idea of mammals.
Mammals are the issue.
Um,
so I decided once I did it like I'm going to try to eat exclusively in my house
only wild game.
I don't really totally do that because occasionally I'll go buy some bison or
something like that from whole foods,
but almost exclusively in my house I'm eating wild game.
Like tonight I'm having a Moose stew.
It's cooking right now.
It's on the slow cooker.
I left the house this morning,
it was on and it will cook for like six hours.
Have you always been into cooking or is it just some of the started with he got
into hunting?
No,
I've always been into cooking.
Some things like I'm really good at making steak.
I'm,
I'm a really good steak cooker and I,
I'm cooked pasta and I cooked vegetables.
Like real simple stuff,
you know,
I'm not making like Keesha's or anything elaborate souffle's or anything that
requires like a deep cooking knowledge.
My skills are limited,
but I know how to do what I know how to do.
You know,
you could throw it some steak on the barbecue.
Oh cool.
I'll kick the fuck out of this barbecue.
The fuck out of some steak.
I know what I'm doing.
That's about the extent of,
you know,
these foods contain the best natural sources of Creatine,
Venison.
Wild game,
Huh?
Oh Wow.
Experts agree that best animal source of Creatine is wild game.
While so there you got all my questions answered.
There you go.
Venison,
elk,
Bison and Buffalo.
What about Moose Bitch?
Moose is the same as gotta be on there.
It's,
it's 100% on there.
Yeah.
It's probably just harder to get because he's just note.
There is no commercially available Moose.
You can get commercially available.
Venison,
elk,
Buffalo,
and Bison.
Which by the way of the same animal.
I don't want to redundant a game meat in the,
unless it's a different type of buffalo,
like there's water buffalo.
But when you talk about the American Buffalo,
you're talking about a bison.
MMM hmm.
Next best source is free range meats,
which includes Turkey breasts,
chicken breasts.
I just shot a Turkey shot a Turkey couple of weeks ago.
That's,
that's interesting.
That tastes different.
You shot in the body,
shot in the head,
shoot the head,
right?
Yeah.
If you shoot it,
the body you destroy spitting out little Nell buckshot pellets.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a dirty trick man.
You put out a rubber Turkey,
you put out a rubber female,
start making noises.
It's like,
Oh boy,
what?
I lacked some cock.
And then they come over looking to give some caucus,
boom,
boom.
Blow his fucking head off.
Yeah.
They don't die easy.
Should feel bad about that one.
I mean that's,
no,
no birds.
Birds can suck my dick birds and fish.
Yeah.
Birds.
They will at least they lay their eggs and then sit on them.
So like they're like one step above and they're kind of like,
I have chickens that I don't want to kill.
You know,
they're like pets,
but if shit goes down,
the power goes down,
I'll kill them before I killed my dog.
That's for fucking sure.
Those chickens are getting it,
but they're kind of,
um,
their pets.
You know,
my,
my daughters will pick them up and hold onto them and they're cute.
You know?
And they're nice.
Yeah,
they're friendly.
We've had them since they were babies.
I mean we hatched them,
I mean not hatched them,
but we got the hatchlings like days after they're born.
The way it works is they actually send them to the mail,
which is kind of fucked up.
They do to the US post office and it's like,
no,
the chicks,
when the chicks are born,
they pack them in special boxes and they send them there.
The boxes have like air holes in them and they send them one day air and it gets
to you,
you know,
express mail,
whatever it is,
ups express,
whatever the fuck they call it.
It gets there.
And uh,
you know,
they give you an alert like,
hey,
it's going to be coming within one day.
And then,
you know,
these animals haven't had any food at all for 24 hours.
When you get them and you get them and you give them some food and they're a
little,
these little tiny things,
man,
you have to incubate them.
He put them in this large box with a heat lamp above it.
So they're in this like little chicken container box and you know,
you feed them and it's,
it's really kind of intense.
Yeah.
What else you got?
You got a monkey or anything?
No,
no much.
There's a,
I have a,
an indoor court yard in my house and while I was on fear factor when I was
losing my fucking mind while I was in full blown losing my mind,
I was actually thinking about filling,
putting a roof over the indoor courtyard,
putting thick glass walls all around it and um,
putting a crocodile monitors in there and like feeding them rabbits,
like having my own Jurassic Park,
like having like a little opening,
throw a rabbit through there and watch,
uh,
the crocodile monitors attack it and devour it.
I'm like,
come on.
That would be the dopest shit ever.
But the problem is those mother fuckers,
if they get really big,
you can't really stop them.
Like if they want to attack you look at like seven,
eight,
nine feet long.
And also their shit is toxic.
Like this shit is just disgusting.
So I was like,
who's going to clean this shit?
I'm going to have some dude come over the house and clean that shit and like get
eaten by the fucking hell.
Yeah.
It was a crocodile monitor.
If you seen one of those,
check it out going the cargo.
No,
it's a,
it's a giant lizard.
A really freaky looking giant predatory lizard.
This is a crocodile monitor pulling up Jamie.
Yeah.
That's Kinda awesome.
If it wasn't for the shit,
I would have been like,
oh,
you'd be fucked up Joey.
Should I go?
I know I came real close to that was pricing.
I was talking to contractors and everything.
See like look at that one of the rat in his mouth down there,
right there at January.
He always thought it'd be fun to have like a Parana tank.
I had that throw.
Fuck yeah.
I had a giant paroxetine for steak in there and watch him go nuts.
No,
the stakes,
not the move to move his goldfish.
You get to watch the attack.
I used to go to the supermarket or the pet store every week and I would get a
large bag of goldfish cause I had,
I want to say I have 30 prawn allegedly cause they were illegal.
Allegedly.
This is a made up story.
I'm just telling you I'm making it up.
This is for entertainment,
entertainment purposes only.
And uh,
I also had a skeleton,
a human skeleton in there that purchased online,
uh,
from like a medical supply thing.
Like you could buy a human skeleton,
which I thought was fucked up.
That's fucked.
It's so fucked up.
That should be illegal.
It's legal.
I had it.
So the bottom of the Purana tank was these skeletons like a skull and shin bone
and some other bones and people would come over and they would look at it and
then they would look closer and they'd be like,
yeah,
I'm fucking real skeleton.
I'm like,
yeah,
that's real scared.
Did you kill somebody and throw it in the tank?
Like shows house houses like the equivalent of like Willy Wonka chocolate
factory for jacket.
I'm definitely coming over next week.
Male children that now that have daughters and everything.
It's all feminize.
They've ruined my whole existence.
But uh,
not really,
but I mean my,
my,
my male sanctuary is now been feminized mixed stream way.
I mean,
I had pit bowls and fucking piranhas.
I was looking to have a reptile sanctuary,
but um,
the parameters were fun.
But you know what's more fun?
The Puranas turtles.
Turtles are motherfuckers,
they're way more vicious than piranhas and you look at them collectively,
you look kind of cute and everything like that.
When turtles are hungry and you feed them Goldfish,
I would feed the Goldfish,
uh,
to turtles as well.
There are way more entertaining because they're way more entertaining and
piranhas.
They're fucking vicious bastards,
man.
And they would grab them with their paws.
They would,
they use their,
the little fins had grabbed them with their fins.
They are,
look at that turtle.
What is he eating?
Jesus Christ tomato or something.
Yeah.
You want to see though that's not a turtle.
That's a tortoise.
I believe.
What?
See if there's a video of turtles eating goldfish.
And what was crazy is like,
well,
these are actually a turtles eating goldfish.
Th they're actually legal.
You know,
we're Paranas since I didn't have them,
because they would be illegal.
Paranas are illegal.
There was a video of like this lady in Thailand,
I think it was tired of that.
And she was like fishing for Paranas.
She had like fucking some sorta gizzard or some kind of meat or whatever.
And she would dangle it in the water and the water's circling all crazy.
And then she would pull it out and there'd be all these Puranas hanging onto the
me.
Yeah,
look at them.
Look at this turtle swimming around.
And they would swim and they would just plow into the pile of goldfish and snack
on them.
And when they get ahold of them,
they use their little fucking hands to grab what their little hands.
I hope this guy gets once we could see it,
but they fucking man.
Hey mangles them.
Look at him.
Oh my kids are getting turtles.
Oh Dude,
they're fun to watch.
But you gotta be careful if your kids do get turtles because they develop all
sorts of funky diseases from a shitty water.
You've got to clean the fuck out of the tank with those clients because ladies,
they're tearing them apart,
man.
They're mangling
these goldfish.
It's fun to watch because you realize like these things are dinosaurs,
man.
They haven't changed for a hundred million plus years.
Still get that dead goldfish.
Just foreign snacking on them.
Can we get the hell off?
Does this happen?
Makes it's like feed him every couple of days.
Yeah,
you feed them every couple of days.
But the uh,
the thing is you gotta be real careful with touching the water and then like
touching your face or eating something like you can get diseases.
Like my wife made me get rid of him when she got pregnant.
Having babies and being around that stuff like you can,
you can definitely get sick.
That water gets real dirty.
They're dirty animals.
They shit it fucking,
it gets,
it gets funky quick cause they're pretty big.
You know,
you're dealing with something that's several inches.
Lawns is shitting in this tank.
And I've always,
I've always wanted a monkey.
Yeah.
And then my girl,
like you have two kids and I'm like,
my grandmother had a monkey.
Yeah.
It wasn't good.
What was that movie with Clint Eastwood had the fuck every which way,
but loose orangutan rank or whatever his name is.
Clyde Clyde.
Right.
Turn Clyde Clyde with punch people out the window.
All the Clyde idiot.
That'd be awesome.
Yeah.
Until it,
this slide is to rips your fucking arm off to death with it.
And I know all that good stuff and I heard they like throw their shit.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
Well,
you just gotta be nice to him.
I'm sure if you're nice to them.
Right.
But you have to be around them all the time.
It's like having a baby.
It never,
never stops being a baby.
Somebody was telling me that they had,
I mean it wasn't that kind of,
forget what it was called,
but it was like they get about,
it was like a little outbreak monkey that's called and uh,
did,
uh,
she was telling me that her dad had bought one off of some people that was like
a,
it was already full grown and loved the dad,
but hated like females get really possessive over the males.
It hated her.
And uh,
you know,
sometimes she'd be cool or whatever,
but they shipped him,
she'd be like attacker and scream and fucking like scratch and shit.
Oh my God,
this is what,
that movie kind of ruined it for me.
Outbreak.
Those,
that's not the one I want.
I want that one.
Oh,
let Clyde,
I don't want the nice guy.
Well,
chimps,
I've thought chimps would be cool to have until that lady in Connecticut,
her friend came over and ate or friend's face to fucking door off the car.
Yeah.
That's like a same thing.
It's like,
it was jealous that this woman was going to be spending time with his
girlfriend.
Who was the wife.
The,
the,
the owner rather that was his in his mind it was his girlfriend.
Right.
Cause he used to hang out with her that he would,
the lady would give the chimp wine,
she'd give them Xanax.
She came Xanax,
crazy bitch.
Uh,
type of crazy bitch.
Just going to have a champion and have them walk around with diapers on is the
same type of crazy bitch just going to give a chimp Xanax like chip was wearing
diapers.
Did you know that by the way?
Huge chimp,
200 pounds.
Imagine chimp as big as you dude,
but only five feet tall.
She just fucking,
it's crazy yoked and just,
there's a video to kind of rip a fuck.
Like he can rip your arm off,
rip your arm off and beat you with it.
This table,
this solid oak table,
smash his fucking thing to pieces if it wanted to,
the amount of strength that they have.
Look at that.
What the fuck and fuck.
That's like Vandelay Silva when he was fighting in pride,
when he fought in the heavyweight Grand Prix.
It's even,
that's,
no,
you know what that is?
That's who some are.
Paul Harris after he did a cycle.
Yeah,
Jesus Christ,
but like 50 times stronger.
The physical strength that those fucking things have is off the charts.
He can't even,
we can't even imagine.
We don't even,
we don't even know what the fuck that is.
I still want one
gorillas.
I love gorillas.
I was like,
I just don't know.
Well,
that was my other thought.
I have this area of my yard that's a one acre blocked off area right there.
Oh,
look at that gorilla.
Jesus fucking Christ.
He's yoked.
Awesome.
Or this guy who's this?
Look at that and that's not real.
That's a fake Brilla Jesus Christ.
Fucking the imagine that murderous motherfucker trying to bite your Dick off to
physical strength that those things have to,
it's not like a man who's built like that.
Did you see the one with the fucking arms on that thing?
You see the one we got the sack on him too.
Oh Shit.
Do you know that a ball size is directly determined by the amount of promiscuous
females around you?
Really?
Yeah.
When you see an animal with giant balls to means he's around hose.
I can't trust these hoes.
You got to have as much sperm development as possible.
You seen that video of that fucking guy from like Ethiopia or somewhere.
It has like a hundred pound testicles.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of dudes like that.
There was a kind of miracle like that for awhile.
Do you see the M in that picture?
There's a hairless bear.
I mean they're bad enough.
You've got to carry them around with you all the time anyway,
but a hundred pounds,
I don't usually bother me.
It doesn't bother me like my regular size balls.
No,
I don't feel the way,
but maybe you've got big of balls and they do
live.
Ever put it down.
He's got a fucking,
maybe we have a smear surrounded by Jose.
Can't trust these hoes like pull up the picture of that hairless bear.
What a fuck is that,
man?
It's funny.
Somebody posted this today.
It was a,
yeah,
15 of the scariest balding and one was or some shit like that.
Yeah,
that's,
I'm a weird animals.
Look when they're don't have hair.
That's a sun bear.
I don't know what those things look like with hair.
It's not a a black bear.
We'll look at that one up there.
The one that far,
not the far right,
but the one next to it.
Keep going.
Yeah,
right there.
Yeah.
Fucking thing.
Jesus Christ.
That's a black bear bear.
Yeah.
Cause that's in Orlando.
So that's a,
uh,
that's a bear with mange.
Creepy fucking animals,
man.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
How weird.
Nature's weird as fuck man.
If bears didn't eat,
what is that?
Is that a baboon?
Oh my God.
That's a hairless baboons.
Oh,
Krav riced.
Where else?
And one stir he can't have is a Hyena.
Have you seen that?
Thanks.
And I like it.
The Africans have a Mike on giant leashes,
like they're fucking toys or they put muzzles on him and shit and gnarly big
chains on their necks.
Hairless Hyena.
Is that real?
Well,
that's what they say.
A chupa copper is,
you know,
the truth macabre.
Like they're always like saying,
oh,
we found a troop of copper.
It's a real animal with a Chupa copper is is a coyote that has mange.
Look at that fucking monster.
Look at that thing.
Jesus Christ.
Those are scary.
They,
those things have some of the huge picture somewhere like this African dude
walking one and it's like enormous.
Go back to that picture.
That mouth open.
Jamie is pimple.
Look at that fucking face.
Oh,
just designed to bite through bone.
That's what that amount is for that fucking baboon right there too.
Oh yeah.
They're creepy as fuck too.
They kill each other left and right to baboons.
Are they killed baboons?
Babies.
They kill everything.
Yeah.
Hyenas are the only matriarchal mammal society that we know of.
The females were actually larger than the males early.
Eh,
keep the males from eating the babies.
Huh?
They also have a fake Dick.
They have a pho penis.
The female Hyena has a foe penis and she'll get on top of the mail.
I'm fucking in the ass.
We were fake Dick.
Shut the fuck up.
I wish.
I was like,
I wish I was lying.
Pull up the video of a female Hyena.
Got To be seen.
A female Hyena fo punk,
two girls,
one cup,
nature's roughest.
Fuck man.
There's a lot of infanticide and then in the animal kingdom where I think that's
the way the world should be.
I think society fucks it all up.
She thinks that's the way it should be.
Well,
however nature wanted it.
I mean,
maybe this is Eileen is doing it that you're going to see actual sex.
I want to see the female penis raping the mail.
Did you Google fake female folk penis?
I can't pay.
This is real.
Yeah.
No,
it's real man.
Go Google images instead of see if there's a,
yeah,
see there's this is this artificial penis that comes out as a she penis.
It's an artificial penis that comes out and the female,
which is larger than male to see show it's an actual penis.
It just doesn't work.
Commercial.
What's not really a dick?
It's just a hunk of meat.
That's it right there.
That's a male.
That's a female right there.
But like they still squat when they pee.
Little like your vagina.
Yeah.
They don't pee out of it.
They just fuck you with it.
Yeah.
Well they don't,
you know,
I believe that that's what,
yeah,
flabbergasted.
Give birth out of it.
No,
60% of the cubs,
the first time mothers die of suffocation inside the pseudo penis.
It doesn't make sense.
Maybe they go down the wrong hole.
Hmm.
I wonder.
I Dunno.
Fuck Hyenas though.
Fuck that world.
The whole world is horrible.
I don't want to hide that anymore.
No,
you don't want a Hyena.
This just,
just so like,
it's like,
like people who say they want bears.
It's like,
you know,
almost all bears are cannibals.
Like all,
all of them,
like especially males,
male bear.
One of the reasons why they hunt males like mature boars is to make the
population healthy.
It seems counterintuitive,
but male bears will eat way more cubs than any hunters ever going to kill like
male bears when they're,
when they come out of hibernation,
especially in the spring when the first things they do is go look for cubs to
eat.
And this is something that biologists are just the easy prey and they don't know
if they're doing it.
They just guess why they're doing it.
They don't know if they're doing it just for food or if they're doing it because
they want to bring the female to estrous quicker.
So it could be both or it could be the side effect of them doing it for food is
the female comes into estrous quicker.
But,
uh,
when I was,
I was bear hunting in Alberta,
we got to watch a male try to get this female's cubs and the female fought in
the mail mail off and we're like 30,
40 yards away from this.
It was fucking crazy.
But where you compensating where,
yeah,
I kind of was.
I kind of what it was,
but my mouth was wide.
It goes from a called Mount on the pier.
They were standing up to it
like attacking,
he doesn't relate to that was pretty good.
I was there.
That would,
it was actually saw it,
but it's kind of fucked when you see it.
Like the guys,
while we were in camp,
one of the guys witnessed a,
a male kill one of the cubs and then,
uh,
he ate half of it.
And then the female came over and chased him away eventually and then she ate
the rest of her own cub.
It's hard out there for a pimp.
Hard hunting.
Yeah.
And none of those three look like a good target or not.
Well,
the mail and wanted to hike up the mountain.
No,
no,
no.
The mail was a good target,
but he wouldn't sit still and he was too far away and he was in between trees
and when he came up to the female,
the female took her.
We wouldn't,
we wouldn't kill a female and we definitely wouldn't kill a female with cubs.
And when the mail came over like he was,
it was like,
it was so quick.
It was also getting dark where you was totally on that borderline where you're
not really sure.
You could see exactly where you're shooting.
Especially with a bow and arrow.
Oh,
it was Bo.
Yeah.
We're archery.
Many times you have to shoot a bear with a boat I shot at once cause I shot it.
Right.
If you shoot it runs you,
you go through the double lungs,
you know with these,
these bows,
the power of these Bose is insane and the real like a Hoyt compound bow 80 pound
poll,
you're talking like 288 feet per second of 468 green arrows flying with razor
sharp broadheads blows right through the body.
I mean,
oh yeah,
these are,
this is in fucking New Jersey Dude.
New Jersey has such a bear population problem.
New Jersey has the largest population of bears per capita in North America.
Big Ass fucking black bears and they're fighting over who controls the garbage.
Like the territory where the garbage is.
These fucking bears are biting each other in the face,
in front of people's cars and the big,
I mean these are several hundred pounds he's fucking bears is that you go
earlier than that.
You get to see them knock over the garbage cans when they first,
yeah,
up there,
back,
back up a little bit.
And they first start duking it out.
Like one bear is controlling.
Well this is this guy's fucking front lawn man.
Is this,
his mailbox is getting knocked over by these bears.
My brother lives in Longwood,
Florida,
and that's like a gated community.
It's like a really nice area.
And every night there's giant bears knocking over the trash cans in the
backyard.
Yeah.
And uh,
I guess the city,
like they won't do anything about it.
Well,
they didn't want to open up a bear hunting season in Florida,
but they're starting to do it and yeah,
in New Jersey they have a real issue.
A fucking kid got killed.
A Rutgers student got killed in New Jersey by somebody in my brother's
neighborhood got mauled.
Some lady got mom.
Yeah,
Dude.
And then he got these idiots that are like fucking leaving food out for the
bears.
Oh yeah.
It keeps them coming.
Yeah.
That's another thing about bears is not like a deer.
If you leave food out for a deer,
it'll eat that food and then go find food other places you leave food out for a
bear.
He knows that's where the food is.
Keep coming back.
So they have real problems.
When a bear like this,
when a bear gets ahold of your garbage,
like these bears there,
they're going to war right here because they've found a spot where the garbages
so look at these fucking guys.
Just Duke.
These are huge bears man.
Cause I keep telling him like,
hey,
shoot the fucking bear.
Yeah,
he's got like two giant English master's.
I'm like shoot the bear feeding them the bear meat.
Yeah,
this is good.
He's like,
oh,
what if I shoot it?
It doesn't fucking die.
It doesn't.
You know
how many shots?
One,
you just go right to the lungs.
Lungs,
Kevin,
listen,
Joe Rogan's giving me advice here.
Double lunch.
They'll wait till it turns sideways.
You get a broadside shot,
you shoot right behind the arms like right where the armpit is right there.
Boom.
Goes right through.
Especially with a bow and arrow.
It'll,
it'll penetrate through both lungs and it will be dead in seconds.
You're talking like 10 feet away.
15 feet.
It's in the yard.
Yeah.
They're not scared.
They're not scared of people at all.
He said,
if he's afraid of is what if he,
you know,
it hurts us and hit a hurts if it doesn't kill it and think of charges him death
possible.
I'm like,
you got five more shots.
Three 57 well,
he's unique.
Use a pistol.
Yeah.
I would use a rifle rifle.
If he's going to shoot a gun,
get a real,
you know,
get a seven millimeter Remington,
ultra Max,
something like that,
and just blow one through him where he's in that gun up 12 get slugs.
I'm going to handle it.
You could,
yeah,
you could go the slug cup.
I'm a fan of rifles.
It's just,
yeah,
it's super accurate.
Very precise.
I want him to miss and shoot the neighbor's house and dog and that's a good
point.
Yeah,
and he wears you left Florida.
Can You suppressors in Florida?
Can you silencers?
Oh,
there's a problem in California.
You can't,
you silent.
There's,
which is really,
does that work?
I saw on the Steven Seagal movie,
He like taped a 20 ounce bottle to the end of it.
I think it's like under siege without work.
Everything in Steven Seagal movies are all actual and factual.
That's the only thing he allows.
He doesn't allow anything in a movie unless it's absolutely correct,
really.
I'm sure he doesn't want serious.
The 20 a two liter bottle of coke or something.
I mean,
I'm sure it doesn't silence it,
but am I like probably takes a little bit.
I'll come in it a little bit off of it.
It's kind of where I was talking to this guy from Sig Sauer yesterday about
this.
Oh,
they tried it.
Let's hear it.
Let's see.
Thought I made that up to me.
Steven Seagal silence 45
that's going to shoot this dude right in the face.
You know he's going to die here.
This doesn't work.
I'm sending it to Jack.
You going to shoot it at the bottom?
At the grounds,
dummy.
Okay,
here it goes.
No.
Yeah.
It wasn't very quiet.
Didn't work at all.
I had to make a suppressor from a flashlight.
Does that real?
Let's see.
Let's see how it works.
Well,
this pull it ahead.
Oh,
this guy's like going deep.
He's building shit.
But it's weird because in California silencers are illegal.
I don't know why.
Because if you can hunt and you can hunt with a rifle,
what a silencer does is it eliminates the sound it,
I mean it doesn't eliminate it totally,
but that big boom,
do you want the boom?
Like why?
It doesn't make any sense.
It's like it's one of those weird things where people aren't,
they're not thinking logically and objectively when they create laws,
like they think that someone's gonna like snipe people and you're not going to
hear it and someone's going to die and get shot.
But the reality is if somebody shoots you like it doesn't matter if there was a
bang or not,
it's the rifle still works.
You have to have a silencer on your muffler.
You have to have a silencer on lawn equipment and lawn mowers.
Anything the have to use some sort of a muffler,
but not on rifles.
You can't have it on rifles.
Yeah,
I don't get it.
I get most of it.
You shouldn't get most of it.
Most of it doesn't make sense.
Not a huge fan of the police force nowadays,
Joe.
It's getting ugly out there,
isn't it?
It's so bad.
It's so just,
just bad.
You know,
I think part of it is,
um,
I think it's just numbers.
You're also dealing with 350 million people in this country who knows how many
thousands and thousands of police officers who knows how many incidents they
have to deal with.
Who knows how many people are in competent and the ones that are in competent,
they get highlighted,
videotaped,
put out there.
And I also think that there's a,
a culture that day have a developed a,
of doing shit in a fucked up way that people don't like,
that they got away with for a long time.
And then cell phones and cameras and youtube came along and now everybody's
super aware of it and you just can't do it anymore.
You just can't do what they've been doing their whole career,
I think,
I mean,
there are,
obviously there are racial issues or whatever,
but I just think that those get highlighted even more.
But I see just fucking asshole cops do an asshole things to every color person.
And it's just that lately it's been highlighted,
but it's like if no one's fucking shooting at you,
stop shooting people,
you know,
when,
when did they become such pussies that like there was a video of a guy walking
out of his house with a screwdriver and like he was literally walking,
it was like with his wife is like 50 year old man.
He's walking out with a screwdriver in his hand like this.
Like he was walking to the mailbox to fix something and the cops like shout at
him like nine times and then didn't,
uh,
didn't like try to help him or anything.
Like,
you know,
when were they responding to it?
What did they think he was,
he was,
he was domestic violence or something.
I don't even know what it was,
but it was like the,
the older woman get walks out and then the husband walks up right behind him and
they were that,
he was like,
oh,
drop it,
blah,
blah blah.
And the guy's like,
what?
And then a little and they shot him like nine times and then they don't even go
up to like help the guy.
You know?
It's like I find almost like these guys are just looking for that opportunity
for when it's okay.
Then more so like when it's necessary.
You know there's a lot of them do that.
There's a lot of them that are just too stupid to be cops.
Yeah,
sure.
But I think most people are unqualified to be cops.
We've talked about this ad nauseum on this podcast.
I just think that we have to appreciate the fact that being a cop is a fucking
ridiculously hard job.
You want to talk about PTSD for soldiers,
but nobody talks about PTSD for cops.
Cops are dealing with horrible shit every fucking day of the week and most of
them are doing a great job and the ones that do a great job,
you don't hear anything about,
it's the ones that fuck up and shoot.
Like that guy in South Carolina that shot,
that guy was,
he was running away and then planted the gun.
Did he plan a gun?
Landed the Taser or something that you watch and he walks up and he said
something else on the floor.
Oh really?
Then the story was,
oh,
he went away for my Taser and it was like [inaudible] my God.
They did that.
But of course that gets spun into the Black Guy.
That was a fucking,
it didn't matter who that was.
He was going to do that same shit too.
You know,
evil guy goes to the issues are and then runs away.
You don't get to shoot them.
You know what?
I'm going to shoot him as he's running away and then I'd hold,
gets a shoot him while he's only going to away and then run up and put the Taser
down next to him.
I didn't know.
I know that.
That's awful.
I didn't know that he did that.
Oh God.
I just think of there.
There are good cops,
you know?
But it's like if you're a good cop,
how many bad cops have you knocked out because you know,
you know how many other ones are in the station.
You know what I mean?
Like,
there's just this,
uh,
you
know,
this like brotherhood of,
you know,
I'm going to stand up for our own and you know,
that,
that's what bugs me about it.
It's always been that way.
My Dad was just really upsetting and disgusting and have kids and to have see
all this shit right now,
it's just really scary.
It's just worried about your son having some asshole cop to something.
Yeah,
I mean,
Mike,
my,
uh,
my wife,
my fiance,
I'm sorry,
bad.
She had set a really bad,
um,
she's,
uh,
she's mixed and like our,
we have two boys and one of them looks white and the other one looks mixed.
I'm black,
you know?
And uh,
yeah,
this racial shit and ignorance is a,
it's upsetting.
Scary.
It should be.
It is.
And I'm hoping that all this anger and all these protests and all these videos
that are coming out and all this,
this,
these youtube videos and all these people that are rising up that's going to
change things,
I hope.
Yeah.
But just seems like Marshall loves coming in like that.
There was something about,
you know,
it's like they're the,
somebody uh,
said something about they're allowing the,
the conditions to eventually go to martial our law.
Yeah.
People say with the way that,
that mass media is like highlighting everything,
it just makes it so much worse.
I just all bad.
I think they're highlighting him because that's what people want to pay
attention to.
Man.
I really don't think there's any concerted effort to create martial law.
There's a lot of conspiracy theories about that stuff,
but I think that's just horse shit.
I think the last thing they want is an armed culture of Americans involved in
arm martial law.
It's just like,
it's,
it's not going to work.
This is not the country.
We could pull that off.
Just not,
you can't take everybody's guns away.
It will fucking never happened.
Yeah.
There's more guns in this country than there are people.
It's just not going to happen.
You're just not going to take away their,
I don't know if there's more guns than people,
but I bet he's close.
He's just not going to happen.
I just think that people panic about that kind of stuff and people always love
talking about some Thai ironical conspiracy with the government comes in.
And even when you try not to,
it's like someone say something and it's hard not to.
Did you grow up in a family with guns?
He had guns,
your family all the time.
Grew up hunting it.
We started hunting and shooting at like 10,
12.
Yeah,
I think I went rabbit hunting when I was 12 of shootings since I was like,
your dad was into it.
My Dad was into it.
My brother and I,
we didn't talk about this the last time and there's was something that was
controversial after our podcast because during the manhood training camp,
your dad died.
Right.
How hard was that man to go through?
My Dad and I had like a weird relationship with my dad and I had like a falling
out probably,
uh,
10 or 12 years ago.
I hadn't spoken 10 years.
And uh,
uh,
he came to one of my fights,
when I've won a glory 10 with arts and Lebanon.
And,
uh,
it was one of the biggest things that Vinny helped me work on it.
I found out my dad had cancer and like my reaction when my brother and sister
told me it was like fucking like,
I don't care.
Like I really didn't care.
He didn't that much that uh,
have
wow did a,
I was just like,
he didn't like,
we had like a really bad issues.
And,
uh,
when I started talking to Vinny,
you know,
I mentioned yeah.
And my dad had cancer and I didn't know how I felt about it because part of me
like carried,
you know,
at some point.
And uh,
Vinny did some like a,
he called it timeline therapy and we had the,
uh,
this is not at all was point on talking about,
but,
um,
we,
uh,
he asked me all of these scenarios like,
think of a time in your life when you were really proud and then think of a time
when you were really upset and like all these different emotions and he didn't
know what he was,
what it was about or what was gonna happen.
He was just trying it on me.
And every one of the things that he talked about was my dad.
Like every one of those times was a time with my dad.
And,
uh,
he did like the,
you know,
the whole session or whatever.
At the end of it I just had no more resentment or anger towards my dad and it
was really weird.
And,
uh,
it was like this chip on my shoulder,
like my whole life.
And,
uh,
at one point for a long time,
I used to think about my dad before I would fight,
when I was fighting professionally,
like I would use,
not necessarily like I'm fighting my dad but like to shove it up his ass,
like,
look what I'm going to do,
you know?
And,
uh,
I realized that like,
that anger that I had and that I used to tap into all the time was actually like
holding me back.
It was almost like a handicap.
And uh,
yeah,
when I,
when he helped me forgive my dad,
I was able to,
uh,
go to Florida.
As you know,
he's got stage four cancer,
he's going to die.
And,
uh,
I had a relationship with my dad for the last year before he died,
that I hadn't had in 10 years.
And that was from that Vinnie helped me do that.
That's got to have a big impact on the way you raise your own sons.
Yeah,
for sure.
Knowing the resentment that you had towards your father and the anger and the,
the bad relationship,
like never wanting it to get to that place.
Yeah.
It was,
it was weird.
It was a,
you know,
Vinny didn't know that he was,
that that was even going to be the result.
He was just like,
oh,
I want to try this timeline therapy thing on you.
And uh,
yeah,
I went from like completely hating him to like just forgiving him completely.
Not like half ass for giving him to like waiting for that apology.
Like there was no apology.
There was no talking about it.
It was like completely starting over and uh,
yeah,
we had like a really good,
a relationship for that last year before he died.
And,
um,
I knew that he was,
he was battling cancer.
My brother started treating him,
he was stage four.
I mean,
it was the doctor's like,
you know,
as your dad's going to die,
he had cancer and as long as cancer in his brain cancer in his chest as she
cancer in his neck,
he had like this giant mass.
I was neck.
And,
uh,
my brother started treating him with CBD oil and,
allegedly I was shipping it to him from here and to Florida or whatever.
But that was probably wasn't very good.
It allegedly,
allegedly there was fiction for fishing or friction informational purposes.
Um,
and we,
uh,
we're giving them CBD oil for about,
I don't,
no,
I guess seven months probably.
And uh,
after,
um,
he wasn't going to chemo,
he just didn't want to do it.
He was like really stubborn.
I'm stubborn.
Guy wouldn't do that.
And uh,
they,
uh,
they tested him.
They did like a graph or whatever to see where the cancer had grown or whatever
over a period of time.
And they were shocked that 90% of the cancer had died.
That there was 90% of the cancer was dead.
And 10% of the cancer that was still alive was like completely surrounded in
dead cells so that they couldn't get even medicine to it and it couldn't grow.
And you know,
it was just gonna he was gonna have to live with it,
you know,
but it was completely surrounded by dead cancer cells.
And the only thing possibly that could have done it was the CBD oil because he
was doing nothing else correctly.
He was like,
um,
you know,
they had them on so many narcotics and pain pills and stuff that he was,
he's a asshole to be around was really hard.
It was like constantly on like this drug thing.
Um,
and he wouldn't eat,
he only wanted to eat was like chocolate cake and ice cream,
you know,
like wouldn't,
it was like really hard for cancer.
We're like,
uh,
you know,
try and get them the right supplements in.
And,
you know,
it was a,
it was a tough situation,
but the,
uh,
the CBD oil was,
was beating the cancer and the cancer wasn't what killed him.
He actually died from like starvation or malnourishment from not doing what we
would beg him to do.
You know,
really well.
90% of the cancer was dead.
Cbd Oil people.
It really works.
It's working right now from my friend's mom.
My friend's mom has stage four cancer and her brain,
uh,
I allegedly got them some CBD oil and uh,
he,
uh,
he um,
got it to his mom,
uh,
within less than two months,
her cancer had shrunk by 30% that she had been doing chemo and they were saying
that her immune system was so devastated by the chemo.
The Chemo was probably going to kill her quicker than the cancer was.
And they had recommended her stopping chemo and he was just in full desperation
mode.
My friends,
real,
super straight edge.
He just,
he's just,
you know,
Mr Republican American doesn't,
thinks Obama's a Muslim,
that Kinda guy and never would want to have anything to do with a CBD oil or
anything.
Cannabis.
I got it to him and now his mom can sleep.
She's eating,
she sleeps at night.
She doesn't have pain anymore or tumor shrinking.
The doctors are astounded.
Those stories,
you hear so many of them,
it's almost like they seem like anecdotal fairy tales because until it's,
it happened to someone you actually know and care about and then you go and then
you start getting angry.
Like this is what these Goddamn assholes that are making laws in this country
and fighting against us,
the lobbyists and the people that are working for the pharmaceutical companies
that are actively trying to suppress this information.
You are keeping one of the best ways to,
to heal these people.
You're keeping it illegal and it's,
it's a fucking horrible crime
and tell you about it,
which is just atrocious.
They,
my dad is there giving my brother the talk that my dad is,
is going to die and it's,
it's terminal and you know,
all this stuff for,
you know,
weeks and weeks and weeks.
He's going to the doctor.
And finally my brother's like,
hey,
so you know,
what about,
you know,
medical marijuana,
is that something that,
and they were like,
oh yeah,
we can prescribe him Marinol,
but we just can't,
you know,
there's no question that the cannabis or Thc,
whatever it is,
uh,
cannabis helps fight cancer,
but we can't,
we can't refer,
you have to ask.
We can't just offer it to you.
And then they gave him that the,
uh,
prescription for Marinol,
which is like the government pharmaceutical form of the pill,
which is probably way weaker than the very old,
and we were giving him,
yeah,
not nearly as good.
So yeah,
like we got the call,
I got the call from my dad or my brother that my dad had passed away.
Um,
I think it was three weeks before the,
uh,
the Melvin man off fight.
And I flew home to,
um,
to Florida to,
you know,
kind of with my brother and sister and figure out the situation where we were
gonna do.
And my brother picked me up from the airport and we went to,
you know,
straight to the bar to a,
have it out about my dad.
And,
um,
when we got back to his house,
my uncle had calls and,
you know,
we just assumed that my uncle was calling to,
give us,
you know,
sorry to,
sorry about your dad.
And my sister answered the phone and my uncle was hysterical.
And,
uh,
I guess my cousin Cody,
who was 23,
I was very close with his huge fan of mine,
um,
had fallen off a balcony on their vacation and died the same night.
And,
uh,
so it was,
it was a ton of stuff to deal with that last,
you know,
two weeks before my fight.
And,
um,
again,
I talked to Vinny and,
uh,
you know,
he helped me stay focused on what it needs to do,
do to handle business in that fight.
And,
uh,
you know,
Vinny foreman can't think of enough of that stuff.
That's gotta be unbelievably difficult to do.
Both of those things.
Unbelievably difficult to deal with while you're trying to focus on,
especially finding guy like manholes,
very fuck,
you know,
every,
every post anybody tags you in is like,
and Man House highlight reel,
you know,
so it's like fuck,
it was tough,
you know,
and it just drains.
You haven't,
I tried to,
I come back and I got two weeks left for the fight and I'm trying to,
you know,
try to stay focused and uh,
I can run it at a good clip and,
you know,
I run six miles,
regularly and like,
I'd be like half a mile in and just be exhausted because all of this mental
stuff just wears on you.
And,
uh,
you know,
I had this internal battle with myself of,
should I pull out of the fight and not pull out of the fight.
And I talked to Vinny and I was like,
you know,
I just,
I don't know what to do.
And,
uh,
he was like,
he's just a dick actually.
He was like,
uh,
he was like,
your dad and your cousin died.
And I was like,
yes.
And he's like,
and that,
that's sad.
And I'm like,
yes.
And he's like,
and,
uh,
you never gonna see them again?
And I'm like,
yeah man,
I'm never see him again.
He's like,
and that's not fair.
And I was like,
yeah,
mother Fucker is not fair,
you know?
And he's like,
uh,
you know,
he says all this shit.
And then he's like,
now what?
And I was like,
what do you mean?
And he's like,
what are you going to do now?
Yeah.
And I was like,
he's like,
are you going to not ever fight again and you gotta not to carry your family,
you're going to let this stop you from everything you've ever wanted to do.
And I'm just like,
no.
And he's like pulling in,
turn off that APP and wait until after your fight handle your business,
you know,
whether you're religious or not at some level somewhere you think your,
your cousin and your father,
what would they want?
And it's like,
well,
I talked to both of them about the fight.
They were both excited about the fight.
I knew what they were going to want,
so I just kind of turned off that emotion until after the fight.
And when I knocked out Melvin,
there's like this,
this,
this moment right after,
like,
the referee stops it at like fucking explode and there's like good bell tours
post the picture all the time.
But like at that moment was like all of that emotion that I had turned off,
like came back right at that moment.
And uh,
you know,
after the fight I was thinking about them and stuff and it was really cool.
Wow.
That's intense.
But there's stuff that's an iconic photo to the photo of you right after you
knocked him out.
It's a pretty intense photo.
That was a crazy fight too,
man.
It was a big one.
Those are the big ones from Melvin is a wild motherfucker,
dude.
Yeah.
Win,
lose,
draw that fucking you're,
you're in for some chaos with that guy.
Right.
Crazy.
Those all those guys from that Mike's jam.
Badr Hari Him.
[inaudible] there's so many of those guys.
Just fucking ferocious.
Yeah,
that's there,
that style out of that shit.
I mean it was,
that's why we're all there.
It is right there.
Yeah.
That was that moment right there.
Well,
we're running out of time man.
So let's end it with that.
That's a fucking perfect picture to wrap this podcast up with.
Does doesn't tense
with Melvin down behind you.
You need that.
You gathered on your gym.
Does that up on the wall?
Yeah,
I gotta put up on the wall.
That shit fucking for sure.
Be Up at the yard,
the yard in downtown La Place train some more tie in California if you're
around.
And a,
if you're in San Diego,
glory 21 is this Friday night tomorrow.
Uh,
and next time you will be fighting is June,
June 26 for ability.
And where is that at?
A,
I believe it's in Kansas City.
Kansas City.
All right man.
Uh,
you can catch him.
Change your Twitter name.
Joe Showing one eight,
seven,
eight better than three,
right?
Was it two or three?
Joe,
Joe Schilling,
one eight,
seven on Twitter.
Thanks brother.
I appreciate you coming by,
man.
Oh,
always a pleasure.
Always a pleasure.
Of course.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen,
we'll be back next week.
We got a full sheds rule,
a podcast.
Thanks everybody.
Much love.
See you soon.
Okay.
Hmm.